from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between McDonald's and Japan and the US
this is food Wars
hey guys Joe from food Wars we're doing
a new season we're comparing the US to
Japan in order to do that I want to
introduce you to co-host and my man in
Japan George hello guys I'm George I'm
from Japan and I like McDonald's
[Music]
so in Japan our McDonald's sodas come in
three sizes this is small
small
and this is Japan's medium medium and
this one is Japan's large
in Japan our chickenback nuggets come in
five and 15 pieces
our chicken McNuggets come in 4 6 10 20
or 40 piece
look at all those nuggets
oh you've been sitting for a while
Japan McDonald's fries come in three
sizes small medium and large in the US
you can get your fries in four sizes
kids small medium and large what is a
little guy
look at this little guy
so this is large fries and I'm gonna
wait them we are going to also weigh a
large McDonald's fry
wow okay so so far our largest are the
same yeah wow that worked perfectly the
thing I just did there great job Joe
[Applause]
now let's measure the medium why not
our mediums are smaller
interesting so this is a Japanese Big
Mac
[Music]
so this is a Japanese spec Mac this is
an American Big Mac and we're going to
weigh it as well
we got a heftier Big Mac here in the U.S
it's more like it it's in Japan the Big
Mac and value set which is a big mugs
and medium fries and a medium drink it
comes out to 690 Yen or 6.21 cents in
the US that same meal costs 8.54 or
948.46 Japanese Yen it's a 37.52
increase in price in the US
what the heck
so here is everything you can only get a
Japanese McDonald's you cannot get in
the US and this is everything you can
get at a U.S McDonald's that you cannot
get in Japan so we're gonna start with
waffle Kongs right here so we got plane
so play means it's like Rich milk taste
and next one is strawberry strawberry
personally I like this the next one is
chocolate and almond right there
hmm it's not melting good job buddy so
here we've got Mac flows so macros mints
there is soda and on top of that there's
ice cream that's it that's it and this
is macros melon
itadakimasu
still sweet
this is grape coffee mug floats
um
and the last one we've got Coke Muk
floats
hmm
oh Joe you definitely try this
yes absolutely I'm trying that when I go
to Japan that looks real good let me
think here hang on a second
okay
we do not have Nick floats here in the
US so I'm gonna make my own on my way
over here I was looking for grape soda
it's actually harder to find than I
thought fanta's not very popular in the
United States but we got this this is
midnight grape Kickstarter Mountain Dew
it's grape
[Music]
haha left over from the Ben and Jerry
shoot stuff is Frozen Here We Go
[Music]
yeah I'm into this these would do well
in the U.S our cold drinks a little bit
different uh we have two exclusive
slushies that you can't get in Japan one
is a pink lemonade strawberry watermelon
yeah dude
it looks real good yes they do have
McFlurries and ice cream in Japan but
one McFlurry you can get in the U.S is
this one it's m M's McFlurry sorry it's
since melted but it's like those uh
those mini M M's I went to the one of
the few McDonald's in the country where
the ice cream machine was working hot
caramel sundae and
the classic fudge sundae so let's go
with soft drinks right here Fanta grape
and here is Fanta melon and this one is
Japanese vegetable juice and there is I
guess more than 20 or 30 vegetables in
it and it's good for health for sure
itadakimasu
ah
we've got cool white grape so can be
done so it can be just like a Japanese
Blended tea
and Japanese people drink this on a
daily basis so next one we've got Earl
Gray iced tea let me show you
wait there is something
there's a mosquito
I have to make a complaint Japan
McDonald's
next one we've got
oolong tea so this is not actually
Japanese tea it's a Chinese tea that's
good for health as well
for health we do have
a mango pineapple smoothie
and a banana strawberry smoothie
smoothies have fruit in it right
oh yeah
feel the nutrients coursing through my
veins
so let's start with this Hawaiian menu
this is limited this one right here is
cheese locomoco oh it's messy
it's a demi glass sauce man and it's
also got
round egg right there beef patty and
some cheese
I'm hungry actually
hmm
oh this is good
oh
this is which means really really
delicious
first the next one we've got garlic
shrimp and it's also got interesting bun
there is Sesame on there and um deep
fried shrimp Hawaiian barbecue potato
and beef
Nicholas sauce again it's gonna be good
this is called barbecue burger right
but I don't taste Burpee at all alright
so next one we've got Hawaiian pancake
with Triple Berry sauce two pancakes
smells so sweet let's go
[Music]
oh
too sweet Mac face Blue Hawaii
wow
it has bright blue color
this is Mac face Cassis and orange
I will get this I will get this so
congratulations this is the worst
okay breakfast time this is a breakfast
burrito oh
neon yellow egg Mexican style salsa not
to be confused with what Canadian salsa
I mean this is actually the same burrito
from the US UK thing we shot over a year
ago so let's go on to these breakfast
sandwiches here Japan does have the
McGriddles which are our favorite of
mine so unfortunately we will not be
talking about those today
sad face I love you McGriddles
so what they don't have and also the UK
did not have were our breakfast biscuit
sandwiches I don't know how to describe
a biscuit other than it's dry
baked maybe they're made with cornmeal
according to the internet this is not a
scone so there you go sausage egg and
cheese our egg is like this fluffy
folded scramble egg egg so there's like
Sunny Side Up ours are scrambled I can
tell this was like folded over you can
see like the fold lines there this is
how we do in the U.S bacon egg and
cheese is there a better breakfast
combination in the world I don't think
there is then they just have the sausage
no egg no cheese just sausage and
biscuit we have regular size hotcakes
and we have a hot cake and sausage combo
of course
comes with syrup and
butter
very natural pose
very natural feeling right now always up
for report yes
breakfast is served
oatmeal on the side to be mixed in
cranberries and raisins and
diced oh
diced apples
and here we've got
Mega muffin pork patties that's huge one
mini pancakes
oh cute it comes with apple cream sauce
[Music]
this is perfect for breakfast I will get
it bacon egg MC sandwich so it's got
bacon and round egg and cheddar cheese
that's it and you might be surprised
we've got little fish tada
so filler fish is on the breakfast menu
I guess Japanese people tend to eat fish
for breakfast three exclusive Burgers
here in the US are variations on the
quarter pounder with cheese yes we've
all seen Pulp Fiction we know about the
whole quarter Ponder thing does not
exist outside of the US I don't think so
probably why they don't have Quarter
Pounders in Japan
the classic quarter pounder with cheese
look at this guy I mean this is maybe my
go-to one for a decade
the quarter pounder with cheese deluxe I
don't know
I feel like this is pretty close to a
Whopper I'm not a big Whopper guy but
there you go a deluxe quarter pounder
with cheese the Double Quarter Pounder
with cheese look at the size of this
thing yes sir
Japan's exclusive Burgers Teriyaki mock
Burger which is my most favorite one my
body is made of my material fiber
[Applause]
oh
[Laughter]
so it's got a Mayo right there and
lettuce pork patties dip it into
delicious teriyak sauce and it's
covering Whole pork patties perfectly
Joe when you come to Japan please try
this you will thank me later
everything that they have looks so good
and sounds so good man when I go to
Tokyo first up I'm going to McDonald's
Sushi Ramen get it out of my face I want
the teriyaki burger that's the first
thing I'm getting when I get there
hmm
I'm getting full actually
working with
slow down George we got a lot of food to
cover
wonderful world baby
all right so we've got bacon lettuce
burger right here it looks sad
egg cheeseburger but we also call it
eguchi egosis is an abbreviation for egg
cheese burger Japanese people love
abbreviation it's got ketchup and pickle
round egg and cheddar cheese and beef
patties next one spicy beef burger oh
look at this oh it looks so spicy
especially mayo or something like that
the sheer we've got Samurai Mak
Samurai
Samurai Mac
yo that sounds awesome and this blue one
is called rasted soy sauce double thick
beef we've got roasted soy sauce bacon
tomato thick beef so if you want a
little bit more like healthy veggies
go for it uh yeah George I don't know if
that makes that much healthier there
because it also has twice as much meat
and cheese if you're looking to be
healthy at a McDonald's in Japan I'd
stick with the vegetable juice and this
one right here is called teriyaki
chicken filet wow so much toast so next
one we've got ebi filio ebi mainstream
so it's a shrimp paleo oh yeah it's got
Aurora sauce Aura sauce is like a
ketchup and mayonnaise
so it's got a lot of shrimp in there
hmm
so good so good in the US we have about
four uh exclusive chicken sandwiches
specifically I didn't see this on the
menu but apparently you guys don't have
a McChicken which is just chicken
sandwich uh regular bun Mayo
chicken
[Music]
yeah we also have check this out
spicy McChicken
so pretty much the same with chicken but
like they put spicy coating on the
breading on the chicken every fast food
chain in America right now is having
what we're calling the fried chicken
sandwich Wars Popeyes uh Burger King of
course McDonald's all of them are at
this arms race to have the best chicken
sandwich I think because Chick-fil-A has
edged everyone out these are the three
that are currently available I don't
know for how long is a crispy chicken
sandwich I think it's a brioche bun uh
pickles
and no sauce which I think is strange
like the whole flavor is just just the
chicken spicy
chicken sandwich same deal but of course
spicy sauce
and the spicy chicken Deluxe which to
George's Point has more vegetables on it
you know to be healthier
okay so when it comes to cider menus
we've got
shakaishaka chicken
and we have two flat oh two flavors can
you hear that
thunder thunder because it's rainy
season in Japan
the sunny season here in Southern
California
and here is red pepper and this one is
cheddar cheese
[Music]
stop
so all you have to do is just put the
powder into the back
and
check it
foreign
big one
like this
[Music]
this I've seen before this I want that's
the thing I want the most of the
Japanese McDonald's U.S McDonald's we
have the bags we have the chicken
just get the spice packets throw one in
we've got side salad and it comes with
this roasted sesame dressing let's go
that was cool now put it all in the
garbage we've got edamame and corn
yogurt
and there is
cow
cow exclusive sauces it's sauce talk
time sauce talk
we have sweet and sour sauce they gave
me
hot mustard this would be honey mustard
you guys a hot mustard I know you don't
have honey mustard of course Ranch
uh ooh spicy buffalo now these might be
promotions because of uh that uh singing
group BTS but we have right now a Cajun
sauce and a sweet chili sauce this sauce
is fantastic this is the sauce this has
to stay on the night so these two are
new ones
this one right here is soy sauce best
salt
man this is fantastic good job very good
taste so this one right here is called
Louisiana hostos oh it does look like
very spicy one
[Music]
this is not spicy at all actually we
were supposed to have buy Burger options
but unfortunately you can only get them
from 5 30 PM but let me explain what by
Burger is buy simply means double in
Japanese so if you order a normal Big
Mac it has two big parties right but if
you order buy Big Mac it has four beef
patties but not not only Big Mac but all
burgers and adapts the buy Burger
options that's funny you can only get
double the meat after 5 30. that's
really funny that would not stand in
this country at all people would lose
their minds four patties I want a Big
Mac
so after shooting this video I'm gonna
order buy Big Mac and then bye bye
health
you ain't gotta tell me George buy
all right here are all the ingredients
for us Big Mac oh good the bun it has
enriched flour which is wheat flour
vinegar and contains wheat onto the beef
patty 100 pure USDA inspected beef no
fillers no extenders prepared on the
grill with seasoning salt and black
pepper there you go there you go
shredded lettuce ingredients lettuce
nice the Big Mac sauce ingredients
soybean oil
[Laughter]
extractives of paprika soy lecithin
the pickle slice ingredients cucumbers
water distilled vinegar salt calcium
chloride Alum potassium sorbate it's
preservative natural flavors polysorbide
extractives of turmeric for color onion
ingredients onions there you go a few
things I want to note Alum is used to
dissolve Steel
Hollis orbit 80 has been linked to colon
cancer in mice cue the dancing mice
and caramel color is on California's
list of chemicals that may cause cancer
and reproductive toxicity good good
Counterpoint they all taste fantastic so
McDonald's Japan doesn't disclose their
ingredients in the Big Mac however they
do tell us where the ingredients come
from if you order a Big Mac in Japan
you'll eat beef from Australia or New
Zealand buns made from wheat imported
from the USA Canada and Australia and
pickles made from cucumbers grown in
Turkey Sri Lanka or India onions grown
in the USA or India
Celeste cheddar cheese made in New
Zealand Australia the USA or Japan and
Lettuce grown in Japan Taiwan the USA or
Malaysia the only ingredients that come
from Japan are the cheese and the
lettuce and even then McDonald's still
Imports some lettuce and cheese from
other countries so this is a very
International Burger
thank you world
foreign
Our Big Mac is 525 calories and 28.3
grams of fat in 1007 milligrams of
sodium and 41.8 grams of carbs and 26
grams of protein in the in the US Our
Big Mac is 500
145 grams of carbs and 25 grams of
protein the US has a slight increase on
everything except protein so in Japan
our five-piece nuggets is 270 calories
and 17.2 grams of fat and 506 milligrams
of sodium and 13.1 grams of carbs and
15.8 grams of protein broken down each
nugget is 54 calories we don't have a
five piece here in the us but we do have
this a 10 piece let's get those stats on
the screen go ahead and divide
everything by two and yes now we have
the stats for a five piece pretty smart
eh if we want to divide all that by I
think five you'll get the stats for one
nugget
so exhausting in Japan if you order a
Big Mac meal with large fries and a
medium chocolate shake the grand total
will be 1 405 calories in the US adding
medium fries and medium chocolate shake
to a Big Mac the grand total is 1660
calories and that is a calorie increase
of 18.14 percent
if you're wondering why we're using a
large fry but a medium chocolate shake
turns out that in Japan you can't get a
large chocolate shake they'll only sell
tea and medium I'm assuming because I
don't want you eating that much ice
cream from a calorie count to portion
sizes we wanted to find out all the
differences between KFC in Japan and the
US this is food Wars
so the fries are the KFC in Japan come
in three sizes so this is small
and next one is back again
then we've got
a box
now let's weigh our largest fries
you can do it
I'm shook as the kids say by that
information I want to say though that
theirs is like a box that thing is like
made to be eaten by more than one person
I'm assuming but this clearly this is
for a person so in Japan we have three
drink sizes so we have a small
in the US our drinks come in now medium
and we got a large large
so in Japan captain doesn't disclose how
much liquid is in each of the sizes why
so I will help you KFC we will measure
the cups right now let's go
okay
so now let's measure our large and just
to make sure it's accurate we didn't
clean the measuring cup
go home
so are the KFC in Japan you can order
your chicken pieces in one piece two
pieces three pieces four pieces
and six stitches
and add pieces
and 10 pieces
and 12 pieces
KFC in the US are chicken portion sizes
start as a two-piece combo by the way
come on guys this isn't whatever is
supposed to be then the three piece
right in front of me here that's the
exact opposite I went extra crispy for
this look at the size of these chicken
pieces yes yes to these and the four
piece this is somewhere in the middle
and each combo comes with a biscuit your
choice of potato either fries or mashed
with gravy and all of them come with a
medium drink but we don't stop there
we're going out of buckets where you can
get an eight piece bucket 12 piece
bucket or 16 piece bucket
so now we are going to weigh our a piece
chicken to compare the weights in each
country
oh
yo that's pretty close considering all
the variables of size of chicken bone
density batter I don't know what I'm
talking about but that's surprisingly
close so in Japan a two piece of
original chicken which are breast and
wing and small fries and a medium drink
cost 800 Yen or 7.27 so Japan actually
KFC is considered a little bit more
expensive compared to other fast food
chains like McDonald's so it's a classic
fast food in Japan that same meal is
about 8.99 or in Japanese Yen
992.27 so that's about a 24 cost
increase in the US it's in Japan to make
chicken at KFC you must be certified as
a chicken specialist and certification
takes three months and your Knowledge
and Skills are tested every year alright
so let's take chicken specialist test
right now right George let's do this
number one for the original chicken 100
domestic that's kind of bummer
[Music]
these got hard fast
I am in over my head on this one I don't
even know what that means all right so
just now I've got all of the five
answers so let's check the answers gold
chicken certification
go
[Applause]
says not KFC material it's a picture of
uh Colonel Sanders giving me the finger
so I'm gonna assume I did not pass it
but anyway I've got a goal I'm the
Champion I am very surprised by that I
think I could work for KFC I mean I kind
of look like Colonel Sanders right look
at this guy
I'm a younger Colonel Sanders KFC is
doing any sort of The Adventures of
Young Colonel Sanders ad campaign is
this a face they can sell chicken yeah
haven't you guys ever read the secret
and putting the energy that I want out
into the universe and it comes back to
me and it's called manifesting
so here is everything you can only find
on the menu at the Cavs in Japan but not
in the US and here is everything you can
find on the menu at a US KFC you cannot
get in Japan here we've got
both places are biscuits but their
biscuit has a hole in it it looks a lot
fluffier right our biscuit on the other
hand is just this southern style not
exactly a scone but kind of looks like
one from a distance dry cornmeal biscuit
it comes with honey maple KFC
oh yeah
this is good the maple it's a little bit
squeezed for me mac and cheese I can't
believe you guys do not have macaroni
and cheese love mac and cheese mashed
potatoes and gravy you don't have that
in Japan guys guys demand this from your
Japanese KFC you want the mashed
potatoes and gravy so we also have deep
packs
so it's got kernel crispy and some
nuggets and boneless Kentucky and some
original chicken so this deep pack it
comes with this price and also these
three dipping sauces and now for the
quickest sauce talk ever
KFC sauce
I think the KFC sauce is like a brown
mustard mayo yeah that sauce is good so
we've got barbecue sauce and mustard and
this pink one is called men Taiko Mayo
men Taiko means is like spicy codural
and it's very popular case in Japan this
is actually great I'll dip this
it tastes fantastic winner
so if you want to have a little bigger
one you can order deep Barrel I mean
it's double amount of this deep pack so
it's gonna be very big so this one right
here is called four piece Red Hot
chicken box and it comes with a pie and
fry
and a medium drink and actually we have
other box options like four piece half
cut and half original box and it comes
with price as well and six piece half
hot and half original box it comes with
fries again
so in Japan we have Torino's pack that
means chicken day it's on every 28th of
the month and two stands for ni and
eight stands for
and it becomes new one and niwa is
synonymous with
remains chicken
so that's why it's called chicken day
KFC in America has extra crispy chicken
this is the best type of chicken I mean
look at this I don't know what they do
to this but the skin is practically
falling off it is so crispy and so
delicious I love extra crispy so much I
got this little guy
a chicken little look at this guy huh
those little guy comes with Pickles Mayo
the pot pie that they have here they're
not kidding when they say pie and the
pot pie how thick this is speaking of
big dishes of stuff the famous bowl once
upon a time a KFC employee was like I
could have put everything into one dish
and call it a day and Tada the famous
bowl was born this has to be like three
pounds all right so here we've got two
special Twisters so this one right here
is called pepper mayonnaise twister
[Music]
it looks great
nine out of ten KFC thank you thank you
for making me happy so next we got oh
Teriyaki twister should be great it's
kind of gross
it's got mayo and Colonel crispy some
veggies and I hope this is teriyaki
sauce
mmm
it looks gross but it tastes incredible
10 out of 10. congratulations
it means delicious look how tiny those
Twisters are I could eat like three of
those easily easily all right so we have
nuggets we have three pieces five pieces
and they come with only ketchup also the
US KFC that you can't get in Japan are
wings you can get wings at the KFC in
units of 6 12 24 or 48. I believe the
three wing flavors that I got here are
standard Buffalo
the honey barbecue and if you're a total
wuss
unsauce what's wrong with you yeah very
sketchy you can also get them in a
limited time Nashville hot sauce now we
have special sandwiches this one right
here is called Japanese style chicken
cut sandwich so let's take a look inside
so it's got mayo and it's got cabbage
and chicken Cuts right there
hmm
oh this sauce is like soy sauce based
sauce and it's a little bit sweet and
this Mayo is also great with this sauce
this looks really small but it has huge
amount of chicken so if you eat this
you're gonna be full
and next one we've got chicken fillet
wow this is also huge all right so this
one right here is called black hot
sandwich
[Music]
look at this it's like pepper mayo I
just tasted this paper Mayo but it has a
little like spiciness oh
oh man it's too strong I wouldn't get it
be careful now of course the US has a
chicken sandwich but our chicken
sandwich and their chicken sandwich as
you can see is way different you can
also get it spicy or Classic this is
classic all right so this one right here
it's called Colonel crispy is it only in
Japan I cannot confirm the difference
between a kernel crispy and a KFC
chicken tender they call their tenders
kernel Crispies and we call our kernel
Krispies Chicken Tenders it's been a
while since I ordered this one but it
still has crispy bits
good job Japanese KFC's technology state
of the art we currently have a Nashville
hot chicken and hot tenders I went ahead
with the tenders I've just been informed
this was a big Tic Tac thing for a
minute something about biting and
crunching it I don't know anything about
that I can say just by holding this
there's no way these are crispy
[Music]
spicy that's kind of spicy I do like
this a lot
okay stop eating up
oh that's Heat's catching up with me
Slow Burn slow Builds on the heat so
here we've got Japanese exclusive drinks
this one right here is
water
but it counts with this awesome tea pack
it's supposed to be hot but it's cold
and next one we've got this one right
here is roasted Rich coffee
it's a little bit better than that
normal coffee and here we got all gray
iced tea it's not sweet at all and next
one is melon soda it has bright green
color
horrible it's too sweet here is ginger
ale nothing special and the last one is
natural refreshing orange found drinks
there's a few that we can get that you
guys cannot over there in Japan the
first one is a beverage that I have yet
to make one human being who enjoys it
of course I'm talking about Sierra Mist
maybe gross the soda ever
so bad another drink that you can get at
KFC if you can't get in Japan and here
it is right here mountain is great when
I was in college I worked at a pizza
place I drink so much Mountain Dew I
threw up and now I'm drinking Mountain
Dew let's see if I can do it again my
favorite beverage Mountain Dew sweet
lightning
so good so good the drinks are just
normal nothing special but chickens are
Finger Licking Good
desserts at us KFC you can get this
chocolate chip cookie recognize that guy
it just looks just like this guy and
finally a chocolate chip cake
so let's talk about Christmas in Japan
so Christmas is one of the biggest
events in Japan even though about one
percent of Japanese people are
Christians we just enter Christmas as
just a fun event and as for KFC for
Christmas in Japan back in 1970s Japan
KFC launched a hugely successful
advertising campaign called Kentucky
that's Kentucky for Christmas and with
that strong marketing campaign it became
so popular to have KFC for Christmas in
Japan and now about 3.6 million Japanese
families eat KFC for Christmas and
talking about my personal experiences
yet when I was young I would eat KFC for
Christmas with my family but when I
started dating you know Christmas makes
the transformation from a family event
to couples event and I I'm looking for
the one who can enter KFC for Christmas
with me
so in Japan one drumstick of
so in Japan one drumstick of original
chicken on average has 237 calories
chickens looking a little limp there
George in the U.S one stiff drumstick of
original recipe is 130 calories but
according to KFC's U.S site that's for a
53 gram piece now adjusting for the 87
Grand piece like that of Japan the
calories go up to
210. does that make sense great now take
this bad boy and make them extra crispy
you got 270 calories so in Japan a two
piece of original chickens and a small
fry and a medium drink is roughly 717
calories a US two-piece individual fry
and medium drink comes out to be 990
calories so a lot more it's too many
calories
um
not enough calories if you ask me but
Finger Licking Good I think KFC got to
George he keeps dropping that slogan are
they paying George I think they're
adding George's getting some money on
the side from KFC oh my God if the
George turns out to be Colonel Sanders
I'll lose my mind
your KFC in Japan doesn't disclose their
ingredients so we emailed their customer
support and this is what they told us
foreign
recipe chicken ingredients are first
with the fresh chicken it is marinated
with salt sodium phosphate and a lot of
sodium glutamate onto the breading it's
breaded with sweet flour so my calcium
phosphate maltodextrin triglycerides
natural flavor kernels secret original
recipe seasoning they also said our
fries are made of potatoes obviously and
vegetable oil
the butter is made of rice flour
vegetable starch and dextrose and our
fries which contain sea salt monosodium
glutamate try calcium phosphate
hydrolyzed soy protein potassium
chloride potatoes D germs yellow
cornmeal and sodium dehydrogen
pyrophosphate to maintain natural color
what's more natural than disodium
dihydrin pyrophosphates rolls off the
tongue and one thing I have to say is
that our fries are imported from both
America and Belgium and some of the
Belgium fries are made with potatoes
from France so our fries are truly truly
French
in the U.S we have four chicken shapes
in Japan we have five chicken shapes let
me explain so we have this one is called
kale kale is like chicken's breath
right here
I'm gonna say chicken's chest
[Music]
kill is like
chicken's chest right there first one is
the breast this is the big piece of
chicken your dad gets and also we got
Wing it's a as you know chicken wing
this is supposed to be a wing this is
laughably small
we've got this one it's called rib
chickens have ribs so rape is like
under the chest right here and we've got
this one thigh thighs like chicken's
lower back
and the next piece is this which I think
is the thigh and of course the next
piece everyone knows the drum and this
is a chicken's leg
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Starbucks and Japan and the US
this is food Wars
thank you
in Japan our hot coffee comes in four
sizes short
short tall
Grande the Grande
and bendy and of course the Venti
um
[Music]
Starbucks episode I'm taking a sip of
everything in Japan our iced coffee
comes in four sizes
short so we start with the tall
too good and
Grande Grande
and bendy now when we get to the ice
venti size it gets a little bit
different so our ice venti 820 it's 24
ounces and then we have a bigger size
the Trenta which is 30 fluid ounces for
your iced coffee aficionados who also
hit your bladder this is the one for you
so in Japan we have this handy coffee
traveler it's 12 cups of coffee so you
just take this off and set the cup right
here
boom
itadakimasu
muy bien
I'm disappointed because our coffee
traveler box is this it's 96 fluid
ounces
so this peels off which is nice yours is
funner than ours I like that one but
this is like
[Music]
we got this boring box look at this
ugh it's like a caveman
together
so here is everything you can only find
on the menu at Starbucks in Japan
and here is everything you can get at a
us Starbucks you cannot get in Japan
holy
a bit of clarification we know that
Starbucks will customize drink orders
and there's thousands of variations of
special secret menu items plus now
thanks a tick tock there are endless new
drinks so these are things on the
official Starbucks menu in Japan and the
US so Japan Starbucks update their menu
very often so by the time this video is
released they might not be available
sorry this one is called go Peach
Frappuccino
hmm
I really love Peach and this is good 7
out of ten noise
go pineapple Frappuccino pink frozen
lemonade and passion tea
it's a little bit sour Yuzu Citrus and
tea
it's the worst what happened to you one
out of ten poja classic latte so hojita
is roasted Japanese green tea that
originated in Kyoto 100 years ago
this is good
fantastic I'll give this 9 out of ten
Thai chocolate Frappuccino
what
oh
too sweet
espresso affogato so afrogato is the
process of pouring espresso shot onto
ice cream
I don't know about y'all with this
again it's too sweet
we've got
dark mocha chip cream I'm so sorry I
spilled most of it the last one we've
got mango passion tea and as you can
imagine this has strong mango taste
I feel like I'm hitting the wall here
guys and you know it would help that
the US does not have as many exclusives
as they do in Japan at least not as
frequently but at the time of shooting
this it is the fall you know that means
Starbucks USA fans pumpkin spice latte
every fall
the entire country loses their mind and
they go by pumpkins and they get
themselves this which is pretty much a
latte that tastes like pumpkin pie
as basic as it is it is pretty good
Starbucks has decided to introduce a new
fall beverage to their lineup and that
is this the apple crisp macchiato let's
check it out
what is this oh man that's terrible
what's wrong with you guys you thought
this gonna be with the pumpkin spice
latte not at all does it sound like I'm
like losing my mind because I'm like
really keyed up right now
I'm gonna do my best to pretend like I'm
not unhinged Starbucks in the US is this
moving on flat white
what is a flat white
this is a flat white
Frappuccinos
strawberry funnel cake Frappuccino
that is really sweet
at a scale of one to ten that gets like
yosios that's how I'm random I cannot
imagine any time of the day wanting that
a wtmoc what is that
eight years
chai cream oh God come on the caramel
ribbon crunch
yeah it's still really bad Java Chip
Frappuccino
nope last one thank you God double
chocolaty chip cream Frappuccino shh
[Music]
that's not nearly as chocolate as the
other one like less chocolate and
there's double in the title and we also
got limited tea this one is called youth
Berry
so youth fairy is Citrus white tea
featuring mango pineapple and acai wow
so it should be healthy and next one we
have roasted green tea we drink this on
a daily basis with breakfast lunch
dinner anytime you want it's our go-to
drink also in the U.S you can get iced
black teas can't get those in Japan I
don't know why you can get these
varieties an iced royal English
breakfast tea latte tea sucks so I have
very little expectations for this
expectations met the next one you have
here is an iced London Fog tea I don't
know what makes it foggy
I don't know and you can also get an
iced matcha lemonade other ice black
teas I cannot get my hands on is the
iced guava black tea and the iced peach
green tea what about that peach one's
pretty good cold Brews and Nitro cold
bruising yourself a Nitro cold brew
right here
and also a salted caramel cream cold
brew
vanilla sweet cream cold brew when I say
I was taking a sip of everyone I'm
taking a sip everyone I'm like caffeine
drunk I bet that was good four hours ago
you get yourself an iced shaken espresso
is that what it says
sound like I'm like losing my mind
all right the honey almond milk flat
white
so terrible it tastes plasticky
so here is Starbucks origami Starbucks
origami is one cup drip coffee system so
it's got six origamis
and this is what it looks like
you unfolded like this so you just put
this over a cup and let's add some hot
water easy peasy Japanese
and Starbucks coffee is served
Refreshers
what a refreshes you ask I'm not quite
sure they look like juice oh it's like
stuff floating in these fruit and stuff
kiwi starfish no star fruit
that'd be worth their starfish in this
these were a good idea good call
Starbucks ooh mango dragon fruit here we
go
bloody strawberry lemonade
very good and this is the strawberry
side lemonade Refresher
not as good iced pineapple matcha I
don't want this at all do it
so here is all the food you can only get
at Starbucks in Japan
so many
exclusive food you can get in the US you
can't get in Japan
breakfast sandwiches I'm going in turkey
bacon sandwich double smoked bacon
cheddar and egg I think yes impossible
breakfast sandwich sausage egg and
cheese classic
spinach feta wrap oh yeah
this is the bacon gouda sandwich you can
get yourself an avocado spread these
little guys are egg bites bacon and
Greer egg white roasted red pepper also
these that I bet are not any good the
kale and portobello mushroom egg bites
no thanks now moving on to Bagels so
what they were able to give me was
cinnamon raisin plant bagel
you can also get cheese onion and garlic
Bagels everything bagels and sprouted
grain bagels and of course they come
with a cream cheese spread so I've got
this shrimp avocado salad wrap
so it's a root vegetable chicken salad
wrap head fire hammer and onion Focaccia
this is a pepper ham and onion focaccia
we've got Caesar chicken focaccia
grilled vegetable and soybeans Hamburg
hamburgu is like hamburger beef patty
nice combination I didn't expect that so
let's go to the next one egg sandwiches
pork patty and English muffin egg and
ham sandwich
mmm
sandwich
it's got chicken tomato sauce
smells nice and next one
big sausage
we got the crispy grilled cheese should
I even open it it's just grilled cheese
right bread cheese you get it the tomato
mozzarella Panini turkey pesto sandwich
how we go are we happy I did that ham
and swiss panini oh the chicken caprese
Panini yeah now we're talking
yeah that's right got the Italian flag
of one sandwich right there uh this one
is the chicken bacon Panini let's open
it up
you can also get yourself protein boxes
there's a bunch of them the one I wanted
didn't have any you can also get a
chicken and quinoa protein bowl so here
we've got baked goods all right so let's
start with this one it's a biscuit
we've got this waffle which really looks
great this cute strawberry cake pop
it's just like art
red bean paste and butter a red bean is
really popular in Japan I know it's kind
of strange but when you come to Japan
please try this our next one we've got
this matcha cake which looks very
beautiful it makes me wanna post this on
Instagram lemon cake also looks great
the chocolate scone and tea scone are
you going to put Harry's face on this
hello Harry and next one we've got baked
cheese tart this is so cute look how
small it is cake pops yeah the cake pops
are big ours are tiny double chocolate
brownie chocolate chip cookie and
although they're pretty popular they
were out when we went in you can get
yourself a marshmallow dream bar
croissants
almond croissants
butter croissants
here we go
chocolate croissant
Hammond swiss croissant Loaves and cakes
banana nut loaf this is the pumpkin loaf
cinnamon coffee cake
sorry about the age lemon love cheers
Danish blueberry muffin and of course
Blueberry Scone we get Harry's face on
that
so here we've got podcast Foods so this
one is avocado cream and cheese tortilla
chips
I will definitely get this with beer now
coffee I need a beer
let's go to the next one in Japanese we
say but this is German right
but I'm curious
oh
it has really strong matcha flavor I
love this wow thank you for coming into
my life chocolate and nuts protein bar
and this one is cheese and fruits 14 bar
if you take a bite you're gonna be
so we've got this yogurt and banana
granola this one right here is Berry
Yogurt and Berry granola
foreign
they got their barbecue chips
organic chickpeas
popcorn
yes
organic fruit puree just eat the fruit
that grew on the tree I put in plastic
first almonds ooh chocolate covered
espresso beans let's
madelines and
sweet potato chips that
that you can also get pre-packaged
shortbread cookies dark chocolate grams
Rip Van waffles and Justin's dark
chocolate peanut butter cups sorry
Justin they weren't there
so here we've got this dessert section
it all looks great right let's start
with this Oreo cookie cake
cinnamon bun
chocolate donut Oreo cookie donut with
this white chocolate
glazed donut
it's so sticky we've got this Jeremy
soup peach tart and this one is lemon
tart we've got this banana cake
and next one cheesecake
all right so last one they've got
Strawberry Tart which looks very great
but I don't have sweet tooth so I'm
going to give all of this to my friends
in Japan a venti latte with no fat milk
is 205 calories
0.6 grams of fat 30.2 grams of carbs
20.6 grams of protein 280 milligrams of
sodium and 225 milligrams of caffeine in
the U.S the same venti cafe latte
contains 170 calories 0.4 grams of fat
25 grams of carbs 16 grams of protein
190 milligrams of sodium and 115
milligrams of that sweet sweet Cafe
our venting
more too much our ventimoka has 450
calories ah yes
venti milk
adult hot chocolate this is a Venti
Caramel Frappuccino in Japan ours has
487 calories it looks really bad so I'm
going to put
whipped cream
[Music]
[Laughter]
us
ah
George your whipped creams look a little
wimpy there buddy gotta do how we do in
the USA check this out boom
take that environment in the U.S ours
has less calories only 470 and brought
reusable straws
I don't get it this is so bad what about
the cost this venti frappuccino is 627
Yen or
5.69 us
can you put the price down please in the
U.S the caramel frappuccino is five
dollars and 45 cents which is around 600
Japanese Yen it's kind of close but you
must consider that the US venti is four
fluid ounces bigger so let's do that
math
looks like it's a bit cheaper in the US
so here is my favorite Frappuccino this
is called matcha Frappuccino do you have
this in the US yes George we do in fact
have the matcha Frappuccino here in the
US too I don't recall putting that in
the script so I think you pulled a fast
one and got us to buy you a frappuccino
so enjoy
itarakimasu
this is delicious excellent
[Music]
Japan Starbucks doesn't disclose their
ingredients so we emailed their customer
support but as of today they haven't
gotten back to us what are you doing in
Starbucks you know just respond to
George
so here is what we do know our
cappuccino is made of espresso steamed
milk and from milk in the US our
cappuccino is made up of milk and brewed
espresso not a lot of info on this
sections not a lot we don't appreciate
being left on red Starbucks our caramel
frappuccino is made of Blended ice with
milk whipped cream real caramel and
espresso
and taste the way perfume smells you
know in the U.S our caramel frappuccino
is made up of ice milk carrageenan
vanilla syrup coffee obviously and the
caramel syrup is made up of sugar water
natural flavor citric acid potassium
potassium sorbet salt monody glycerides
soy lecithin and sulfates a Japanese
caramel macchiato contains vanilla syrup
milk espresso and original caramel sauce
and ours in the U.S contains milk brewed
espresso vanilla syrup which is made of
sugar water natural oil flavors
potassium sorbate citric acid corn syrup
butter cream salt monodiglyceride soy
lecithin and sulfates
from Toleration to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all
doing Pizza Hut
in the US this is food Wars
in Japan a Pizza Hut pizza comes in 3
smallest comes in the my bowl
and is approximately 15 centimeters
[Music]
our small can only be made on a
gluten-free crust check it out looks
like something you would get in your
high school cafeteria and it measures 10
inches or 25.4 centimeters our next size
up is a medium which is 26 centimeters
I'm gonna take this little guy
this pizza is so good dude
and our large pizza is 14 inches or 35.5
centimeters
[Music]
this my box
1080 Yen or out of bask cheesecake for 1
290 Yen or get three my boxes for 3 000
Yen and you can get a free style menu
item like a 1.5 liters of Coca-Cola also
for those wanting a little alcohol you
can get on my box deal with an alcoholic
beverage for 1 100 yen it's called being
tipsy set
[Music]
ah
see
[Music]
now I'm going to the boxes baby our next
size up is a 13 dinner box it is a
medium one topping pizza breadsticks and
cinnamon sticks this is the best idea if
I had to go into an office this would be
my briefcase this is what I take to work
every day
now you're probably thinking ah Joe I
want more food in a box well Pizza Hut
of course has you covered with the Big
Dinner Box ahem oh it is the Big Dinner
Box this is
two one topping pizzas with wings or
breadsticks that's what I got of course
you could also get pasta and breadsticks
you can also get que Papas and
breadsticks or just a third Pizza all
for 23.99 to 24.99 man dinner is served
you can get chicken on the bone in two
pieces four pieces and add pieces that's
really cute Japan two Wings in the US
our wing orders start at 6 12 18 and the
biggest order you can get 36.
[Music]
a spice expert because this is nothing
dude I've had spicier LaCroix
here is a Japan large Basic pizza we
call our cheese pizza basic and it is
2030 Yen or
18.39 U.S and it has a surface area of
754.77 square centimeters so that is
about
0.024 dollars or
2.63 Yen per square centimeter the U.S
large cheese pizza is 13.99 or 1 544
Japanese Yen it has a surface area of
989.9 square centimeter which breaks
down to
.014 cents per square centimeter or
1.54 Japanese Yen much cheaper here in
the US so here are two large basic
pizzas this one right here is hand
tossed dough and this one right here is
a palm pizza here are two large U.S
cheese pizzas one of them has the pan
crust and one of the has the hand toss
crust both are the same size and the
same price we want to find out which
gives you more pizza for your money
let's weigh a slice of each and compare
go
so winner is
[Music]
no oh wow that's like that's crazy how
good I did just here look at that
same price 25 more pizza
[Music]
you can get that Japanese Pizza hat you
cannot get in the US and here is
everything you get at a U.S pizza you
can't get in Japan Mexico
got everything on here in half and half
and in medium size on hand toast crust
all right so let's start with this one
so I got this toku
Uma means special delicious so it's
special delicious bulgogi and this one
is menta potato mayo bacon menta means
spicy called raw and it looks good so
next one we've got double shrimp with
special lobster sauce and this one is
Grand barbecue asparagus bacon and this
one is potato sausage Mayo next one
we've got crumbling
pulled pork and next one spicy pulled
pork select the cheese and thick cut the
burrito and this one is super supreme
Mexican carapeno Cara means it's like
spicy so spicy jalapeno on there and
next one is Snappy potato sausage and
this one is green and yellow veggie
pizza shrimp Mayo Menthol and this one
is addictive anchovy and black olive
first exclusive us pizza pizzas this one
right here is the meat lovers Pizza look
at this thing you see that this thing is
pepperoni Italian sausage ham bacon
seasoned pork and beef that's every meat
that's every meat in the store I think
uh this one right here is the Hawaiian
chicken pizza this looks like one bite
would like send me to my grave this at
least has a vegetable on it
the green peppers were a mistake this
one right here chicken bacon parmesan
chicken bacon tomatoes and a parmesan
crust oh yeah dude look at the crust on
this you can bake the cheese running the
crust I just love that pizza it's like
we gotta cover the every serving which
is God forbid you take a bite doesn't
have cheese in it in Japan you can get a
pizza with four different topping areas
called the four Series so let's start
with this one it's called gochi so for
gochiso means feast
and next one we've got bulgogi Festa
four
so let's move on to the next one we've
got lovers or lovers
what
is this for this beef it's gonna be
horrible
and this one is called kodawari or
kodawari means authentic
and this one in front of me is Gourmet
Mania 4.
what did I do to you Pizza Hut it's
burnt look at this
all right next one
and the last one is classic four this is
classic
this one right here the Backyard
Barbecue Pizza barbecue sauce instead of
pizza sauce I think and it comes with a
barbecue honey shall I I think I shall
oh yeah I think I'm gonna like this
don't sleep on the uh the pizza at honey
barbecue this is really good I think
this is buffalo chicken pizza Tangy
buffalo sauce
exact opposite problem I think the sauce
ruins us too strong skip the sauce so
this one right here is a Japan only
pizza so this is a pizza with the
sausage crust with bukogi teriyaki
chicken Camembert cheese gouda cheese
green chili sauce shrimp squid tuna Mayo
broccoli corn basil sauce and anchovies
too much but let's give it a try look at
this
too much
[Music]
disgusting
in the first place I hate anchovies
don't put anchovies
it's just
I picked out that pizza for you George
sorry my man gotta do it for the show
and here's the USA only Pizza it is a
pizza with toppings and sauces and
cheeses you can only get in the U.S and
not in Japan first got the gluten-free
crust remember that that really sad
looking crust uh we can have a creamy
garlic parmesan barbecue or buffalo
sauce as a base I went with the creamy
garlic Parmesan it's got meatballs
banana peppers and for the crust I
pretty sure I want the garlic parmesan
[Music]
it's not awful when you order food and
you're like really hungry so something
sounds like it's gonna be really good
but then we start eating you know like I
think I screwed up this is definitely
like scriptive
so here we've got Japan's exclusive size
we've got chicken nuggets and this is
four pieces eight pieces 16 pieces and
we also have plain flavor and spicy
flavor let's try this
[Music]
please
everything is explain
spicy very spicy nuggets
and next one we've got honey cheese
balls so cheese balls there and we've
got honey syrup so next one we've got
Japanese style pasta chicken so this
chicken is marinated in soy sauce and
rolled in potato starch instead of wheat
flour and deep fried let's talk about
U.S exclusive sides can't get these in
Japan Pizza Hut also got pasta referred
to at one point as Pasta Hut you can get
two of these baked pastas at our Pizza
Huts one is the Tuscany
what'd I say
this is fine no Tuscany is to uska and
why they sell this one with
t-u-s-c-a-n-i no come on I'm looking it
up keep rolling now with pizza
in your face just an absolute abuse of
Italian culture here is the Tuscany
chicken alfredo pasta and the Tuscany
meaty marinara pasta if I can't put a
finer enough point on it I do not want
to eat this at all this looks like a TV
dinner like this is what you eat in your
apartment sitting in a folding chair one
light bulb hanging from the ceiling
eating this just right out of the oven
staring at a wall looking at like
cockroaches run up and down you know one
window has a view of a brick wall the
calendar on the walls from three years
ago nobody wants this k-pops what are
K-pop as you ask I don't know
they got like jalapenos and stuff in
them so they're kind of like spicy tater
tots these to me are like quintessential
Pizza Hut sides we got breadsticks and
we got cheese sticks they both come with
the marinara sauce we also have a
marinara sauce you guys don't have
sauce talk so here is extra sauces so if
you want you can get green chili sauce
or honey syrup so the Wing Street Wings
you can get at Pizza Hut also come in
exclusive flavors you can't get in Japan
here are all the sauces
spicy garlic is really good Joe's sauce
seal of approval Teriyaki this seems
like a no-brainer but we're not gonna
leave it to chance
no oh is that correct this is terrible
it doesn't pass garlic parmesan oh look
there's like parmesan like on top of it
yeah
that might be the best one
lemon pepper dry rub why do I have to
apply it
yeah I'm not into that man I don't get
it I don't know what Drake's going on
about man lemon Pepper's not very good
crucifying the internet I don't like
lemon pepper dry rub Wings should I
think maybe I should be rubbing it
that's what I'm doing wrong
is that too much
whoop yep you're right too much
what's good also sauces real quick we
got blue cheese we got Ranch so share is
Japan's exclusive desserts here we've
got Basque cheesecake we've got lady
Barton vanilla ice cream
and last one they've got lady Burton
chocolate ice cream desserts we got them
in the U.S you can get yourself this a
set of six Cinnabon cinnamon rolls this
is the triple chocolate brownie I'm
starting to lose it guys all that pizza
it just hit me this right here is the
ultimate chocolate chip cookie this is
pretty funny they should cut this like a
pizza cinnamon sticks they also come
with a thing of icing
maybe my obituary photo
[Music]
I can't believe how good that is this is
the Cinnabon thing I want to try it now
since I had it before I want to see how
compares to that
Cinnabon is still better in Japan our
Fountain drinks are Coca-Cola products
in the US our soft drinks are Pepsi
products you know what that means this
is soda Wars in Japan we have Coke Coke
Zero and Fanta grape and green tea and
who who orange juice look at this face
[Music]
orange taste classic Pepsi
Cherry Pepsi Diet Pepsi Orange uh your
crush right yeah Orange Crush Mountain
Dew and of course Sierra Mist which is
like Mountain Dew only
so much worse
so Apple Pizza is
2256 calories
112.8 percent of your daily recommended
value too many calories
in the US our large cheese pan pizza has
eight slices and each slice is 360
calories so for the total pizza that's
2880 calories that's 144 of your daily
calories and both the fat and the sodium
are each over 200 percent of your daily
allowance Japan's large pepperoni
Supreme with Plum bread crust is 228
calories per slice or
[Music]
2736 calories for the entire thing which
is
136.8 percent of your daily calories
even more calories
this is a large U.S pepperoni with the
pan crust man it's a thick guy one slice
370 calories that makes the whole pizza
2 930 calories and that is 146.5 of your
daily allowance now I would like to
point out that the large pepperoni pizza
is the most popular Pizza Hut pizza in
the U.S but not Japan online it rakes
about the 14th most popular in Japan one
of the pizzas we enjoy is the seafood
mix it's one of Pizza Hut's best sellers
for over 20 years wow so Japan's most
calorific Pizza is the large toku Uma
bulgogi and I forgot to order fresh
tokunabul Gogi sorry about that but this
one is
and this one is smaller but large
Celeste Pizza is 285 calories which
makes the entire large pizza on plant
bread crust 3 420 calories
[Music]
yum
in the U.S our most calorific Pizza is
the meat lovers I also was supposed to
get the large this is a medium if
someone Graphics could just make this
pizza much bigger or me much smaller one
slice is 470 calories making the total
Pizza which should be eight slices
3760 calories that's more than double
your daily fat and triple your daily
sodium I am a glutton for punishment but
I'm not going to bite into this pizza it
looks like a knife
there's a few ingredients to watch out
for at the Pizza Huts in the U.S one is
an ingredient found in our salad
croutons it is called
azodicarbamide
Azo
azodicarbamide or 88 it is a substance
use for making vinyl foam plastics for
things like yoga mats and it's also in
our croutons I'm not quite sure why the
use of this additive surprisingly enough
is not permitted in Japan what that's
just horrible both yoga mats and sellers
have a connection to health but U.S
solid croutons have actually plastic
yoga mat plastic how ironic also in the
U.S you're going to want to watch out
for yellow number five AKA tartrogen
which appears in these Cinnabon minerals
oops I already ate one according to the
European Union this chemical quote may
have an adverse effect on activity and
attention in children and quote it is
banned in the EU not banned here in
America and it is at least not allowed
at any of the Pizza Huts in Japan so you
can totally get this here in America
let's get some deficit on that attention
may have adverse effect on activity and
tension in children I mean it's having a
horrible effect in my attention as an
adult
I stopped paying attention to what was
coming on my mouth moments ago so the
dude got yellow number five as well
Orange Crush has yellow number six and
red number 40. remember those are bad
too
all the color things are bad
say this
is terrible why the hell American fast
food chains could harmful chemicals into
their foods do they make their food in a
chemistry laboratory or something
use the kitchen
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out the biggest
differences between Subway and Japan and
the US this is food Wars
[Music]
in Japan our sandwiches come in three
sizes this one is regular and here we've
got
fulong sub and
this one right here is priority tray
this is Purdy tray a which is three
regular sandwiches cut into 12 pieces or
we can also get a party tray that's
three fullong subs and you guys you have
three sizes six inch foot long and the
party tray this is five foot Longs cut
into three section giving us 15
sandwiches not enough part in that party
platter Subway's got you covered here in
the US you can also get a three foot
party sub
whoa whoa
yes yes
time to give this sandwich an exam dude
are you kidding me look at this I'm
seeing ham I've seen turkey I'm seeing
cheese
and also we have a giant sub let me show
you
I got this oh
and this is what it looks like
this is too big
[Music]
in Japan
are Fountain drinks come in three sizes
this one is small
and medium
and large
here in the U.S Subway the website says
this is small but I talked to the subway
manager and they assured me they don't
have a small so apparently art found
drinks are just two sizes medium
which makes no sense because there's no
small
and large
[Music]
at Subway I had to fill up myself they
found drinks which of course I don't
mind so any inaccuracies rest on my
shoulders and my shoulders alone
40 what not even close and that was like
I filled this up to the brim I'm looking
through this I'm seeing 33 maybe we'll
be generous we'll give them 34. I still
missed it by six
six fluid ounces you guys are skimping
on us
and get a good shot of them is that real
is that really six missing ounces do we
think that's six ounces of fluid
roasting there
you better believe him on a high horse
right now this is infuriating I'm really
hungry that has a lot to do with it too
on the surface both country sandwiches
look the same but we wanted to get a
closer look here we have a foot long on
white turkey with lettuce tomato black
olives and onions all right I've got the
same one so I'm gonna weigh this
wow so pretty close
scientific accuracy is really important
with food Wars so
now let's open it up and see what's
inside
huh only a 10 gram difference but ours
had a lot more turkey and a lot less
vegetables hmm
[Music]
so here are all the Subway menu items
you can get in Japan but not in the US
and here is everything you get a U.S
Subway you cannot get in Japan so let's
start with new exclusive sandwiches so
here we've got tandoori chicken sandwich
the chicken itself is standard nine out
of ten congrats
so next one we've got tokumori tandoori
chicken sandwich
tokumori means extra large so extra
large tandarin chicken sandwich we've
got spicy egg shrimp
so next one we've got chocolate chicken
and cheese sandwich
this is not good
it doesn't have any taste man what the
fudge it's the first thing I have this
huge pile of sandwiches here I'll just
try and do some hits here is of course
steak and cheese
buffalo chicken yeah I don't know maybe
it's because they put all the veggies on
here too they kind of just did
the standard ones that I don't think
this looks very good oh the Cali turkey
looks like there's spinach on here oh
and bacon yeah okay
hmm not bad they're ruined it with the
Cucumbers the clove cut combo this is
like the sandwich right if we were
playing Family Feud and the category was
Subway sandwiches I feel like the cold
cut combo would be number one right oh
the Baja Steak everybody straight from
Baja California
you know their blast now try their steak
everyone in the room just groaned
I have to know how far is that bathroom
from here
they're really loaded with the
vegetables again why would you want all
these gross veggies and I want the
meatball and I want the sauce and the
cheese I don't want cucumbers a meeple
sandwich it's ruined I'm sneaking a
meatball
yeah the Italian BMT come on this is
like the most popular one let's look at
the meat there nice looking meat right
like nice looking meat they can lift up
the meat
[Music]
who ruined the sandwich of vegetables it
is the spicy Italian
looks like the BMT but yeah dude in
Subway's defense these sandwiches were
made what three hours ago at this point
so here are Japan's exclusive regular
menu
so let's start with this pizza bacon
Italiana
I would rate this seven out of 10.
so next one we've got prosciutto
mascarpone
shrimp avocado and I love avocado next
we've got
turkey bacon egg
perky as you can see bacon right here
and egg paste
it's not that great and next we've got
chili chicken sandwich
this is terrible hey
how dare you
okay I'm getting full but let's keep
going here we've got avocado vegetables
mmm
[Music]
next we've got egg sandwich
all right one thing I have to mention is
that most of these sandwiches can be a
salad so if you like salad go ahead but
Jill wouldn't get this for sure what a
Subway get a panini press or something
like look at this this sandwich isn't
like grilled them or whatever okay this
one right here is the BMT
so I'm just guessing for the melts they
do it on the white bread and they had a
bunch of cheese and they just Grill it
right I mean I can't even open it's like
it's locked buffalo chicken melt maybe
there's less vegetables in it so maybe I
do want this and I don't realize it
steak and cheese a Philly cheesesteak
right I know this one I know this one
tuna melts
turkey melt yeah I guess I mean I gotta
say like I I haven't tasted them but the
effort in these are just like what are
you guys doing I mean they just like
flatten them
ham melts what's SP again
it should be s i but it's SP for spicy
right so I'm like wait a second is this
a spaghetti one we've been talking about
meatball melts what do they do they
flatten the meatballs in there right
nice batter less vegetables right this
is the chicken vacant melt
so this is the Japan only sandwich
everything on here you can't get in the
US it's a six inch on Sesame bread with
tandoori chicken mascarpone cream cheese
egg salad shrimp chili sauce and wasabi
soy sauce this is a mystery sandwich
I said Wasabi soy sauce right I got
Wasabi attack
it's hurting me
let's get too many flavors and it makes
me confused this here is the USA only
sandwich a sandwich comprised of only
ingredients you get in the United States
and not in Japan so let's start with the
jalapeno cheese bread it has meatballs
American cheese pepper jack cheese
provolone cheese banana peppers good God
spinach Ranch sriracha and pepperoni
ah here we go
that's actually pretty good
I really like this dude oh cool it's not
too spicy the jalapeno Bread's really
good the meatballs and the pepperoni
work really well together like I said
the banana peppers are actually welcome
in this it kind of makes a little
sweeter I think
Subway put this on your menu
this is really good I challenge you all
the viewers in the United States start
ordering this sandwich let's put the
pressure on subway to make this uh make
this like a featured sandwich this is
good
so here we've got snack sandwiches but
this one right here is Uncle sandwich an
ankle is a staple of traditional
Japanese sweets The Taste can be enjoyed
alone or as a compliment to other
Japanese flavors such as matcha and here
we've got angko and mascarpone
I have an announcement to make Subway
has breakfast I'm just a surprise to all
of you specifically they have four
breakfast sandwiches here in the U.S a
bacon egg and cheese a Black Forest ham
egg and cheese egg and cheese and steak
egg and cheese I don't know which one is
which I think this is the steak egg and
cheese
oh it's flatbread too so I can kind of
this looks like a cartoon look at this
look at the eggs
are you kidding me with this in a Subway
in the U.S you can get just about any
one of their sandwiches as a protein
bowl from what I can tell that's their
way of calling this a salad so you know
my feelings on salad
I hate them just an example though we
got what looks to be a turkey one
everything that comes in a sandwich
which instead of bread is bull and once
you're done you can throw it in the
ocean kill a sea turtle cheers it's a
waste it's an absolute waste eat a
sandwich like a normal person there's
nothing wrong with bread eat it it's a
sandwich yeah and it's like the shredded
lettuce too it's not like you know like
leafy lettuce or spinach in it it's that
shredded they put in the sandwich
so here is Japan's exclusive size now
this one right here is korokoro potatoes
original flavor and next one we've got
korokoro potatoes triple cheese flavor
Korea potatoes herb salt flavor the
korokoro means is like rolling over and
over like
rolling over and over and last one we've
got corn cream chowder
yeah I do chips chips
chips
get yourself the bake lays I mean
the Undisputed ship champion in the
United States right here baby nacho
cheese Doritos
a favorite a classic glaze we just want
to see what potato chips are like in the
50s get yourself a bag of classic lays
on this Vicky's jalapeno and lime crack
pepper I don't think I've had the uh
lime Cracked Pepper
these are so good
Sun Chips I hate Sun Chips
here's a side that you can get in the
U.S you can't get in Japan I'm gonna go
Muscle Man's applesauce so here is
Japan's exclusive drinks this one right
here is ASCII and Pepsi melon soda
oolong tea which is Chinese tea iced
coffee soy cocoa
and this one right here is vegetable and
fruit juice which has 11 kinds of
vegetables and three kinds of fruits and
this one right here is Pepsi Zero and
this one is mocha as Cafe Ole and this
one right here is ginger ale and soy
latte soy mango mango orange mango juice
mocha and milk tea cocoa hot black tea
and herb tea in the U.S as you notice we
have Coke and Coke products at our
Subways so we have Coke and they also
have to go bottles so I went ahead and
got Diet Coke
Sprite
and Gatorade the fruit punch all right
sauce talk sauce talk I couldn't get any
of them on the side but we have
exclusive sauces here at the subway in
the U.S we can get a red wine vinegar a
yellow mustard a creamy Sriracha a
buffalo sauce of course we also have
Ranch Chipotle Southwest marinara sauce
sweet onion sauce and MVP parmesan
the most valuable parmesan apparently I
was surprised to learn that the Japanese
Subway doesn't have cookies the cookies
are actually pretty good in the US you
can get a chocolate chip cookie an
oatmeal raisin cookie a raspberry
cheesecake cookie and a white chip
macadamia nut cookie all right so let's
move on to Japan's exclusive sweets so
let's start with this one chocolate
brownie
we've got cheese tart
and this one right here is cream soda
float and this one right here is cream
latte float and coffee font
[Music]
in Japan a six inch turkey sub on White
Bread is 261 calories in the US that
same turkey sub is 270 calories so
pretty close but I did notice ours has
much less sodium like 26 percent less
our six inch tuna sub is 361 calories
and our tuna is 430 so a little more but
much more fat I have not eaten turkey a
tuna anything on purpose ever it smells
like cat food don't you think it smells
I guess most cat food is too and I'll
say yeah this looks super gross but I
have to try it right let's see if like
my distaste is misplaced
you know I hate that man
do you like calories in Japan our most
calorific sandwich is the pizza bacon
Italiana 1 6 inch is 436 calories in the
US are most calorific sandwich is the
chicken and bacon ranch just six inches
of this bad boy is 500 calories so foot
long is a thousand calories
in Japan our regular sandwich with a
small drink and small serving of
potatoes the total calories for this
meal is 498 calories in the US a six
inch turkey sandwich with a small drink
which the subway I went to said they do
not have and a bag of chips I went with
the classic lace is 750 calories
in Japan this meal total is 790 Yen or
7.23 us in the US that same meal is 9.14
or about
998.26 Japanese Yen roughly 26.4
increase
in Japan we focus on having a healthy
diet or cholo Cuts meals chokatsu means
having a healthy diet that contains a
lot of dietary fiber in order to keep
your intestinal environment healthy and
it's getting common in Japan to have
Tall Cotton meals at home or even at
restaurants because a lot of Japanese
people have a constipation problem due
to a lot of stress and lack of exercise
so Subway offers a special meal called
chokat's chicken and cheese sandwich
which contains a lot of dietary fiber so
it's gonna help you return to regular
bowel movements and you can start your
day with a number two
so we don't have anything like that but
I can only speak for myself that if
you're experiencing
constipation in the United States May
recommend the steak and cheese at Subway
foreign
Japan does not disclose all the raw
ingredients but they did provide the
main raw ingredients for their breads
Japan Subway flatbread contains wheat
flour yeast vegetable fat and oils skim
milk powder wheat protein salt sugar
barley mold powder
Etc well our Subway in the US does give
us the ingredients and our flatbread
contains all of others now there's a few
similar ingredients and there's a bunch
that are pretty close that Etc in the
Japan flatbread that gives me pause I
mean if that's supposed to represent all
of this other stuff that is a huge dot
dot dot or to be continued or yada yada
yada a Japan's throwing at their uh
their customers I mean if the America
has proven anything it's like you can
tell us what's in the food we don't care
we'll still eat it so I don't know
what's up with the ETC guys Subway's
tuna was a bit controversial here in the
US starting in January where a class
action lawsuit made false claims about
their tuna meat the drama continued when
a New York Times article claiming to
have had a lab analyzed 60 inches worth
of Subway tuna shared the results saying
they could not identify a species of
fish and no amplifiable tune of DNA was
present in the sample Subway responded
of course saying it uses 100 wild caught
tuna and even launched a website Subway
tuna facts.com to give everyone a clear
and transparent look into their tuna
process furthermore USA Today did their
own fact checking and had its doubts
about how the times tested the tuna
samples and pointed out the lab tested
for five tuna species out of 15 and
concluded the tuna was too processed or
that there was no tuna DNA different
tests have detected tuna in Subway
sandwiches and experts say canned tuna
can become denatured when cooked then I
did my own scientific research to find
out what denature means and the
scientists at dictionary.com said dear
Joe thanks for reaching out to
dictionary.com the word denatured means
to destroy the characteristic properties
of a protein or biological micro
molecule by heat acidity or other
effects that disrupt its molecular
conformation they went on to say for
further definition inquiries please just
use the search function on the homepage
as that is what's there for don't email
us so believe anyone another Subway
ingredient controversy that's a bit more
clean cut at least for the good people
Ireland is that an Irish Court ruled
Subway could not call their bread bread
due to its high sugar content in Ireland
for bred to be considered bread the
amount of sugar in the dough must be two
percent the flower's weight Subway's
bread however the sugar content is 9.2
percent
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Taco Bell in Japan and the US
this is foodworks
in Japan Taco Bell standard tacos come
in orders of one
two tacos with fries
and a drink
or you can get five pack
or you can get 10 pack
in the US our standard Taco Bell tacos
come in orders of one three with a
medium drink or this the 12 taco party
pack check this out
I mean they're not kittens as a party
you roll in any party with this you are
you are the party winner right so this
is a beef taco supreme it measures five
inches our beef taco supreme that's
falling apart because I'm an idiot is
exactly five and three fourths inches
and let's weigh this and it weighs
boom
it weighs 100 grams looks like about 120
grams and this one is our burrito in
Japan and let's measure it five inches
our bean burrito is six and three
eighths inches long and it weighs
he weighs 220 grams just a a hair over
250 grams yeah ours weighs more
hooray
here's our Crunch Wrap spring it
measures six inches across let's go
it weighs exactly 250 grams a personal
favorite the crunch wraps oh man
oh guys I mean you get the idea but it's
just it's just like a thing of beauty
when they have the whole thing folded
properly plus also now on my
I think inside's kind of exposed across
it's exactly
six inches
huh Illuminati stuff coming at you six
sides six inches
we're on to them here they come
if we go point to point it is the
less interesting six and a half inches
so we'll weigh it
you have no idea how bad I just want to
take a huge bite out of this thing it
weighs a respectable 300 grams that to
me sounds exactly right at the Japanese
Taco Bell the biggest menu item is
[Music]
the variety setup
it includes two grilled burritos which
is chicken and two chick Stars which is
Fried Chicken Crunch Wrap spring and
here is four crunch tacos which is B and
here is Natchez
all for 5 000 yen or around
35.49 us did George just say 45.49 for
the just the largest menu item that
can't be right that is so much money
everything on this end is 157 just their
largest thing it was almost 46 bucks
that's wild the biggest single menu item
we have in here in the United States is
the before mentioned Taco Bell Party Box
this is exactly what it looks like is a
pack of 12 tacos and in America this
runs you 22.99 or around
2526.80 Japanese Yen
so here is everything you can only get a
Taco Bell in Japan you cannot get in the
US and here's everything you can get at
a U.S Taco Bell you can't get in Japan
probably I'm very confused
I don't know what half of this stuff is
so these are Japan's special menu items
but before getting started I got a
mention one thing is that I have never
tried Taco Bell before this is my first
time I'm so excited George I can't
believe this is your first time trying
Taco Bell uh congratulations and I'm
sorry so here
naked chicken taco
I don't know
let me try
it
this shell is not the usual taco shell
it's actually
chicken shell
You Rock My World
so here is DIY Target kit I'm gonna make
my own special tacos which is called
George's special tacos
GSG yo I'm gonna go with this crunchy
shell I don't have spoons so I have to
do like this
one more time you gotta be gentle
I'm going to use this one
I have a good idea
I gotcha put some lettuce
put some cheese
tomato
I
prefer mild
this is what we call GST itadakimasu
[Music]
George has made his special taco and it
is like the most
average Taco maybe he was like he was
like meat cheese tomatoes and so I hate
to break it to you George but you made
like you just made a
I said like a soft shell taco what would
my
Taco bee
what would my Joe's
signature Taco Bell taco Dorito shell
right everyone's on their head follow me
so far wrapping to gordita right
then the steak okay
then Tapatio I don't know if that's on
the menu there that queso from Chipotle
that's what's good right I could put
that on there guacamole there's a taco
chain in the midwest called Taco John's
and they have these little potato things
called potato Ole so I put some potato
Olay some Taco John's on there so we
have it then we deep fry it I need a
dipping sauce what would I what would I
uh if I was to dip what would I dip it
in give me a sauce
sour cream you're out of your mind
terrible what do you think
as a ranch we'll go with ranch
spicy mayo this guy's criminal over here
like that's Taco Bell guys get real
there's Joe's and only Joe's
signature Taco get it going it's got to
collab with Chipotle and Taco John's USA
exclusive tacos at the Taco Bell Taco
Bell or Doritos or both had the
brilliant idea of going why don't we
make our shell like a Dorito
and for some strange reason they still
have non-dorito shell tacos which I
don't understand why because it is far
superior to any other regular taco shell
they have on their menu look at this
thing look at this thing I'm salivating
looking at this nothing including
oranges are this orange naturally this
is just a whole level of food chemical
engineering and I applaud it Doritos
Taco Bell here we go
oh my gosh so good
George you got to come to America you
gotta try this Chalupa Supreme I'm
assuming that's this the black bean
chalupa well we always saw that yeah
there's a thing that looked like itself
the Cantina crispy melts it has a deep
fried shell and then other nasty beans
all the veggies and then this must be a
crispy melt the gorditas crunches are
they take a regular Taco covered in
melted cheese nacho cheese and then wrap
a uh
tortilla around it Taco Bell answered my
prayers by making a gordita crunch that
has in fact the Dorito shell inside of
it they use yeah and they use cheese to
melt it to the hard shell best idea ever
gotta know
yeah yeah something stuffed in something
with melted cheese is everything I want
is it good
yeah the vegetarian is that why you've
had it
oh what would you get not meat at Taco
Bell okay I understand all right to each
their own the spicy potato soft taco I
hear from a very good source very
reliable sources this is good so gotta
know
oh yeah dude
down here
we do not have available The Loaded
Chicken flatbread or the loaded black
bean flatbread uh they are on the
website they weren't available here
we've got cheesy core burrito we've got
cheesy beef burrito we've got cheek star
which is Fried Chicken Crunch Wrap
spring burritos I'm already tired
quesarito beefy five layer burrito
burrito supreme black bean crunch up
Supreme cheesy roll did we see the
chicken chipotle melt yeah those one
ripped open was the chicken chipotle
melt so here is Japan's only cider menu
we've got crispy chicken our Taco Bell
in the U.S you can get a side of black
beans and rice or guacamole so here are
a few menu items that are the same but
so different between Japan and iOS
our notches come like this the chips and
toppings are separate I got two avocado
sauce and tomato and cheese and sour
cream and in the U.S and also Mexico I
assume you get your nachos with
everything already piled on the chips up
until recently I thought one of the key
descriptors of nachos is that it's chips
with stuff piles on it but in Japan they
give you the chips as you can see and
they have like each ingredient in a cup
and you can kind of mix it I think that
is ridiculous this is what nachos I know
this like these are Taco Bell nachos
they also have the make your own taco
kits and then they get to make your own
uh nacho kits I don't do that we call
our chips Mexican chips and they are
tortilla chips that are flavored doing a
complete 180 I am very jealous that
Japan has flavored tortilla chips I like
tortilla chips just fine
um the nacho cheese at Taco Bell I'm
gonna be honest with you it's just okay
but I think flavored chips with this
cheese would actually be really good
we'll take an L on that one but it's the
only one we've taken this whole video so
that's fine our loaded fries in Japan
are topped with beef and cheese and sour
cream and here in the US our loaded
fries
are not existence wasn't on the menu the
one I went at they are on the website I
don't know if it's just a Southern
California Taco Bell thing our load of
fries have beef lettuce ranch red strips
cheese and tomatoes sounds very good
we were supposed to have Taco Bell
desserts as well
but the store I went to
didn't have them so here's a list
ice cream
cinnamon tostada
and chocolate
I want to try chocolate
that's all I can say
our desserts we have these little guys
Cinnabon Delights we all know what
Cinnabon is we all like to be delighted
looks like a little munchkin that may or
may not be Cinnabon flavored let's find
that together
holy so these are Japan only drinks
we've got Coke and Coke Zero
drinks sip sip baby look at all these
colorful drinks you eat and drink with
your eyes so I've been told so naturally
the whole color of the band chemical
rainbow right in front of me here with
every yellow number this red number
there blue in the whatever so I'm gonna
assume none of these are in Japan
because of whatever's inside of them I'm
just going to list I'll just do like a
few hits Pepsi we know that right they
got Coke we got Pepsi Sierra Mist I hate
that so much
Baja Blast oh God this is Mountain Dew
Baja Blast right here more on this in a
moment
oh good God also we have here is
Mountain Dew Kickstarter orange this
actually rules
so this uh urine Pantone color beverage
can only mean one thing that it was
swiped up the side of Dewey Mountain
ladies and gentlemen Mountain Dew
I will go to my grave knowing that
flavor All Too Well I don't know why
this don't have regular fruit punch they
have the Gatorade the G2 Gatorade fruit
punch pink lemonade so I heard
that's pink lemonade is just lemonade
that's dyed pink
what's a pink lemonade that makes it
pink it was it was originally like it
was invented by I think like a traveling
circus and they just did it kind of like
to get people to buy it like it was a
novelty was pink instead of regular
lemonade color but I'm assuming now they
do so they must do something in pink
lemonade to make it taste
that's Limited
what makes pink lemonade different from
Lemonade I want to know our Taco Bell
also has coffee and iced coffee and
although I would never drink this
unsweetened diced tea Taco Bell's got
breakfast in the US and I have to say I
think that their breakfast menu is
fantastic if it looks a little scarce it
is because I don't think they gave me
everything and I'm confused on what some
of these things are because everything's
kind of wrapped they used to have like
then they used to have like a waffle
taco maybe maybe I'm just imagining that
they got a Cheesy toasted breakfast
burrito
and a Cheesy toasted breakfast burrito
with potato and of course they have a
hash brown toasted breakfast burrito
which I think is this hash brown toasted
breakfast burrito with steak which is
right here and of course the grand
toasted breakfast burrito which is right
here and of course they have the grand
toasted breakfast burrito with steak and
then they have a Breakfast Crunchwrap yo
this one has eggs and potato in it it
looks ridiculous but for real and these
are hot at like 9 30 in the morning you
can't beat this as a matter of fact
this is so good
you've been sitting out for a couple
hours it's still awesome
Taco Bell's breakfast is great it's
they're no McGriddles but if the
McDonald's isn't available I go right to
Taco Bell breakfast you can also get
hash brown Casino
breakfast Salsas these are really good
orange juice the homies over at
Tropicana hold it down
let's talk about nutrition in Japan a
big crunchy taco is
164.4 calories it has 87.2 grams of
protein 5.5 grams of fat
14.7 grams of carbs and 293 milligrams
of sodium in the US our standard beef
crunchy taco is 170 calories 8 grams of
protein 9 grams of fat 13 grams of carbs
and 310 milligrams of sodium so we lead
in calories fat and sodium or Japan has
more protein and carbs the next one is
the chicken quesadilla ours has
492.51 calories this one has 510
calories one thing to note that in both
countries one of these quesadillas
hovers around half of your daily sodium
sodium at Taco Bell appears to be such
an issue that the US menu online certain
Combos and items like this one right
here are labeled with sodium warnings in
Japan I
have a crab spring has
1280 milligrams of sodium that's 56 of
your daily allowance our Crunchwrap
Supreme is 52 your daily sodium that's
more than half right man so both
countries way too much sodium are you
looking for the most calories in one
minute
in Japan it's our loaded fries one order
is 718 calories it has a third of your
daily calories almost half your daily
fat and 66 percent of your daily sodium
in the US the biggest thing you should
look out for are the nachos the very
popular Nachos Bell Grande I love you
guys is 740 calories
1050 milligrams of sodium okay now the
Cinnabon Delights do have more calories
930 but technically that's a 12 pack
which is supposed to be for four people
I'm certain if you're like me you're
getting 12 and you're not sharing them
some do most don't but obviously the
Nachos Bell Grande is for one person but
the most calories line an item that's on
Taco Bell's Cantina menu which is only
available at certain locations here in
the US there you can get something
called the Grande beef nachos which has
1120 calories which is more than half of
your daily allowance and 68 of your
daily sodium
now it's just not the food at Taco Bell
you also have to watch out for the
drinks here it is everyone 30 fluid
ounces of Mountain Dew Baja Blast a
beverage that answers the question what
if we combine Mountain Dew's bold
refreshing tropical flavor with crystal
meth this totally logical 30 fluid
ounces of nightmare fuel is 420 calories
very cool and 110 grams of sugar I'm
sorry this stuff is making me Delirious
hmm
[Music]
after a few ingredients at our Taco Bell
you should look out for both are in the
beverages on the Taco Bell's Cantina
menu first is brominated vegetable oil
AKA BVO which is bad to Japan BVO is an
emulsifier found in Citrus flavored
sodas and is specifically used with
Citrus oils and it's considered a health
risk when ingested in large amounts it
was brought through public attention
when it was discovered in popular
beverages like Mountain Dew and Powerade
but due to public pressure it was
removed from Coke and Pepsi products in
2014 which is good now unfortunately you
can still find this ingredient in three
Cantina menu freezes the beach Berry
freeze the ginger mule freeze and the
party punch freeze luckily there weren't
any of the freezes you find in the
regular menu only on the Cantina menu
ah
okay when it comes to Citrus flavored
soda we have CC lemon that's one of the
most popular Citrus flavored sold in
Japan CC lemon contains the following
sugars which is fructose glucose syrup
and sugar and lemon juice flavoring
vitamin C acidulant safflower dye
calcium pantophenate vitamin B6 carotene
pigment that's it see it doesn't have
brahminated vegetable oil it tastes
really good
so that means you can make it delicious
without BVO
the last one party punch freeze also
contains yellow number five AKA
tartrazine which is subject to
restrictions outside of the US in places
like the EU and Japan as it may have
adverse effect and activity and
attention in children what the hell you
can tell this color is yellow right
so why don't you use something else that
isn't harmful just like C C lemon
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Kit Kats in Japan and the US
this is foodworks
in Japan our kitkats come in four sizes
big little pouch bite Minis and bar and
classy one Sublime so one thing to note
here regarding mini sizes the regular
KitKat is 11.6 grams but the flavored
minutes such as matcha are said to be
slightly smaller 11.3 grams so I'm gonna
weigh them now to confirm so let's weigh
a regular flavor KitKat first
it weighs 11 grams but it doesn't show
the decimal points it suggests 11 grams
let's weigh much of flavor
12. it's really heavier than regular
flavor interesting Japanese kitkats have
become popular all around the world in
the US of course is no exception I just
want to mention the top here we're going
to be talking about Kit Kats that are
native to our countries I know you can
get them online I think walmart.com has
some of them fantastic they're imported
we know thank you in the US our kitkats
come in nine sizes starting from the
smallest we have a KitKat minis
unwrapped then the thins Miniatures
snack size standard forefinger the big
cats from there we move up to king size
which is a piece accidentally broke off
and then I accidentally ate it the big
cat king size which looks like just be
two big cats and the biggest size the XL
a bag of KitKat bites should have 11
bites let's count in Japanese each need
11 bytes and according to the bag the
combined weight should be 50 grams so
let's weigh all 11 bites
it weighs
50 kilograms good deal all of our us
sizes come in a variety of units
depending on your KitKat needs so many
varieties here's a few worth mentioning
the mini is the biggest bag of minis
unwrapped you can get is 419 grams as
the title implies these things are
unwrapped little bites it's so like it's
for sharing but get real whoever sticks
their hand in here first it's their bag
for the Miniatures according to Amazon
you can get up to four pound bags AKA
1814.37 grams and what it looks like
they just sent me a bag that's Loosely
four pounds of KitKat minis all the bars
have their various packs none of them
seem unusual I will however mention that
the biggest single purchase of the
KitKat item you can get is the king size
24 pack the total here is 2040 grams
about 4.5 pounds of KitKat
here's all the kitkats exclusive to the
US and here is all the kids got native
to Japan KitKat in Japan is made by
Nestle and is one of the best selling
candies in the country one of the
reasons for its popularity is that
KitKat has a good luck charm in Japan
because the name KitKat in Japanese is
which means you will surely win so the
KitKat brand became associated with good
luck and these kitkats are often given
to students before their exams for the
past 10 years KitKat has introduced more
than 350 unique flavors wow some of them
are discontinued unfortunately and some
of them are original so we could look at
them by the filming of this episode
so here are a few standard KitKat
flavors in Japan coffee break but it
doesn't taste like coffee but goes well
with coffee so I brought my coffee with
me today so let's see how it goes
foreign it's actually pretty good much
better than expected so next we have
melon
hmm it's so melon it has way too strong
melon flavor next we have chocolate
orange
overall not bad next graham cracker
this is fantastic next I'm gonna go
cheesecake
this is marvelous if you're a cheesecake
person like me you will definitely like
this next strawberry cheesecake
you get some decent strawberry flavor
and cheesecake flavor at the same time
which is amazing next apple cinnamon
I'm no big fan of this there's a lot of
cinnamon in it which makes this horrible
pistachio look at this cute squirrel
Kawaii
it's not great but not horrible either
next pudding
it's disgusting
it's way too sweet let's go next one we
have strawberry milk
holy crap
this is nasty
this is the worst one so this is the
last one I've got cookies and cream
this is the best thing I have ever had
in my mouth sorry to interrupt but
believe it or not the US does have a few
exclusive flavors you can't get in Japan
first up
pumpkin pie
yo this is exactly like pumpkin pie yeah
they hit it out of the park with that
one wow key lime pie
this one's so good it tastes just like
key lime pie these are both fantastic
Broody cereal
what cereal is this is that Fruit Loops
tastes exactly like fruit loops
gingerbread
raspberry cream
I love this one yo joe really all right
try it let's go what do you guys think
yeah yeah Starburst good call Witches
Brew crispy Wafers and marshmallow
flavored cream
these are great yeah it has like um a
frosting flavor to it I got uh glow in
the dark wait what's supposed to glow in
the dark the packaging or the that's not
fun I thought if this was gonna glow in
the dark the packaging let's see it
let's give it a shot
nothing's glowing uh lights back on a
little regular quick crop there's a
regular how disappointed is taking a
thumbs down
birthday cake
looks like a frosting and sprinkles
flavor that's all really good also in
the U.S you get a lemon crisp flavor
sold out everywhere it was like a
supreme drop the second those hit the
shelves are gone also KitKat in the US
has this line called Duos as you can see
three different flavors two flavors and
one we got mint and dark chocolates
it's just like Thin Mints mocha and
chocolate yeah I'm already I'm not
predicting this is gonna be anything
special
interest okay
and dark chocolate is the way I'm eating
these annoying
I mean it's not terrible but if it's
strawberry and chocolate have been too
sweet with the dark chocolate
so these were fun right these were fun
no
all right back to Japan KitKat has a
collection of flavors inspired by the
many versions and prefectures of Japan
so I'm gonna start with this Mount Fuji
the highest mountain in Japan it's
3776 meters high and the flavor is
strawberry cheesecake flavor how can I
open this
here we go it looks great
it's pretty good but it tastes exactly
the same as the one that I tasted 10
minutes ago all right next one is this
shinshu apple shinshu is kind of very
all the way to called Nagano prefecture
and not gonna prefecture is located in a
center of Japan and is famous for
delicious apples and finally they turn
into kit cuts
oh this is the nicest chocolate I've
ever had next we have amau strawberry so
it's basically from tushu Kyushu is
Japan's third largest island and is
located Southwest of Japan and amahu is
the best brand of strawberries in Japan
marvelous again next I'm gonna go with
this one
are named after uji City where they're
grown and the difference between matcha
and hojita is much as much right matcha
is a green tea but ho jija is a roasted
green tea let's go with ujimate first
matcha is always perfect
it's as beautiful as my heart let's move
on to the next one we have benimo benimo
which is purple sweet potato it's from
Okinawa so Okinawa is Japan's
southernmost prefecture and is famous
for benimo okino is my favorite place in
Japan
I love this he has just right sweetness
we've got azuki sandwich flavor from
Nagoya so Nagoya is located in between
Tokyo and Osaka and it's famous for its
azuki sandwich azuki is with red bean
paste so sweet red bean paste sandwich
oh it's not my taste at all
flavor it's from Hiroshima so Hiroshima
is located in the southwest of Japan and
it's famous for its Momiji Manju which
is kind of maple leaf shaped cake filled
with sweet bean paste
it tastes exactly the same as this one
sweet red bean paste Japanese people
love sweet red bean paste Hokkaido azuki
and strawberry flavor hokado is the
largest and northernmost prefecture in
Japan and it's famous for its
okay
much better than the other asuki flavors
why Wasabi and it's from shizuka and
shizuka is located along the Pacific
coast and is the top Wasabi producing
region in Japan
believe it or not it's actually pretty
good let's go this one strawberry
cheesecake flavor again it's from
Yokohama Yokohama is located next to
Tokyo but yokama is not famous for
strawberry cheesecake I don't know why
they chose strawberry cheesecake flavor
for this
it is exactly the same same next we have
Tokyo banana so Tokyo banana is a banana
shaped sponge cake with cream filling
and it is very popular souvenir of Tokyo
and they turn into
katicats
[Music]
it's gross when you come to Tokyo you
should try turkey bananas but you should
not try but
rum raisin
it's from Tokyo Tokyo is not famous for
ramirezin which says Rama resins
gorgeousness and fanciness matches the
image of Tokyo
[Music]
there is a shot of rum I don't like it
it contains a lot of alcohol
last one sake flavor which is a Japanese
traditional alcohol made from rice this
is a really interesting one
oh personally I like it and this is like
an acquired taste so when it comes to
sake flavor we were supposed to have
yogurt sake use a sake limited edition
Japan sake umeshu but these were not
available at the time of filming this
and we have KitKat desserts we have
KitKat colliders which I cannot find in
the filming of this but it looks to be
almost like vanilla flavored cups with
KitKat chunks broken up in it
too much too many kitkats and then we
have these these Kit Kat ice cream cones
I I hit a wall real hard
Giant
KitKat XL wall and I want I officially
do not want to do this anymore
better but not by much more yeah so
that's it for the US sorry we have so
few flavors Japan has a KitKat called
otonano Amazon which translates to
sweetness for adults
are again don't let your kids watch this
part all right so it's a line of KitKat
flavors that are a little more bitter
and less with the regular cat Cuts so
here we have Otona namasa strawberry
White
and dark matcha and dark chocolate
alright so let's give it a try first
this is just straight up dark chocolate
as you can imagine strawberry
who is actually tart this is good all
right so let's move on to the next one
we've got dark matcha
this is so deep much deeper than the
other butter flavors so last one we've
got otonano Amazon white chocolate
this is the best one among these Otto
Nano Amazon chocolates just right
sweetness alright so let's do matcha
taste test in Japan matcha flavored
kitkats are so popular over the years
we've introduced 13 different different
different matcha flavors but currently
we were only able to get these three so
let's see how different they are first
dark matcha
deep matcha
but it's also deep he told you among
ujimacha
so freaking hard to tell the difference
but I'd say this one is the most
delicious one Kyoto
we can get it in Kyoto or order online
so here we have classy chocolates called
Sublime so we have white Sublime and raw
milk Sublime and a volcanic green
Sublime and orange volcanic subrime
yellow Ruby Sublime all right so let's
try some out I'm getting sick of the
sweetness
it doesn't taste anything I was thinking
that you know like it tastes like
strawberry or raspberry or something but
did I get coffee
okay let's keep going all right so I'm
gonna go yellow volcanic volcano
this is the bitterest I've got Ranch
beer
now I'm so scared green Sublime
it tastes exactly same as this too so
bitter next we have milk Sublime
it tastes exactly the same as regular
flavor I prefer this one last one I've
got white Sublime
compared to the
otonanoamasa white chocolate it's much
better I'm done
hey guys it's Harry I can't let you do a
kicker episode without me because
kitkats were actually invented in the UK
in 1935. they would eventually be
distributed by Nestle across the UK the
EU and Japan but in the US kickouts are
made and distributed by Hershey's if you
watched our Snickers episode you'll know
that there are some major taste
differences between the chocolate in the
UK and the US mostly that the UK's is
way better I'm really a three-way taste
test between UK us and also a Japanese
KitKat to see if there's any major
differences between the three and Harry
thank you for sending me this with your
cute handwriting thank you Harry
let's try you'll get first
the UK one is obviously the one I'm used
to the chocolate is very smooth not
overwhelmingly sweet and just very tasty
the UK is already like a lot richer
[Music]
okay okay can I try yes KitKat I also
couldn't find just the standard American
KitKat anywhere I guess we didn't bother
importing the regular one the closest
thing I could find was this KitKat Duos
mocha and chocolate one
something doesn't taste quite right
about that well you okay U.S they suck
they both have too much sugar Joe Harry
try Japan
much smoother creamier in terms of
picking your favorite I think the US one
gets discounted immediately then between
the UK and the Japan one it's kind of a
different style of KitKat I guess I
would say Japan and UK are pretty neck
and neck they seem very similar Japan's
kitty cat is the best in the world not
eating too much candy
perhaps we can pinpoint The Taste
difference to the ingredients in the U.S
a KitKat is made up of sugar wheat flour
our kitkats have the following
looking over the ingredients I noticed
our kitkats have cocoa butter and
chocolate although it does not specify
what that chocolate is made up of do we
assume it is the same as the Hershey's
chocolate bar I don't know whereas the
Japan KitKat has coca Mass cocoa butter
and cocoa powder now we're to believe
that Nestle in Japan holds the chocolate
to the same standards they do in the UK
it would mean that it would have a
higher fat and Coca content according to
the UK rules a product must contain no
less than 25 coca salads to be
considered milk chocolate us definitely
does not go by this rule our KitKat is
made up of palm oil where theirs is
vegetable oil same in the UK it is
cheaper but is also worse than the
environment adding to deforestation
increasing Greenhouse emissions and
water pollution so it is bad in the
environment and tastes worse fantastic
but good news for all you vegans Nestle
has created a vegan KitKat with
substituted milk with a rice based
alternative but availability is
currently limited so they are not
available in the US or Japan
this is a U.S KitKat miniature it is 8.5
grams it's the closest size we have to
Japan's mini this is 42 calories 2.2
grams of fat 6 milligrams of sodium 5.8
grams of carbs four of those are sugar
and one gram of protein in Japan the
mini is the most popular size it's 62
calories and 3.5 grams of fat 3.5 to
11.4 milligrams of sodium 8.99 to 19.4
grams of total carbs and 0.9 grams of
protein the most common KitKat size in
the US is the four finger bar 210
calories 11 grams of fat seven of those
are saturated 20 milligrams of sodium 28
grams of carbs 23 of those are sugar and
2 grams of protein the closest size we
have to do that in Japan is the kit cut
bar it contains 224 calories the most
calorie KitKat in the US we got is the
KitKat XL now I unwrapped it here so you
can see just how big it is it contains
640 calories the most calories you will
get in a KitKat in Japan is the big
little pouch bite this bag is 275
calories
from calorie count to partial sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Burger King and Japan and the US
this is food Wars
here's everything you can find on the
menu of the Burger King in Japan but not
in the US here's everything you can find
at a US Burger King you cannot get in
Japan alright so let's start with
exclusive Burgers so here we have
Teriyaki lettuce burger and Teriyaki
Whopper
oh
cute
next we have avocado salad burger and
avocado Whopper
a little cute baby
look at this
and
Walker
totally different
this one is so huge and avocados tomato
no tomatoes I don't know why next we
have cuatro Cheese Whopper oh
big boy
[Applause]
we've got Smoky Barbecue Whopper and
Smoky Barbecue Whopper Junior and here
is spicy Whopper
foreign
it's hot sauce
next we have tartar chicken burger
it's got
a lot of tartar sauce chicken crispy
Burger King in Japan just released a
brand new burger called guilty Burger
it's basically butter burger why what
have you done let's check out this
guilty butter beef burger first the bun
is different
just a little bit of butter flavor but I
don't feel as guilty as he claims this
one is guilty butter Crockett sandwich
[Music]
and
here is guilty butter chicken burgers
first one is something that BK has
exclusive oh my God this is called the
Texas whopper
[Laughter]
two patties cheese bacon bunch of
veggies wait for it
the triple Whopper look at the size of
this thing the weight of it is
completely flattened the bottom bun and
there's nothing between the patties of
meat
what the hell are you guys doing over
there next uh no the bacon King
oh God looks to be a pretty
bacon-centric looks like a Double
Whopper with cheese bacon Mayo ketchup
mustard they didn't mess with the
veggies thank you you're not fooling
anyone getting lettuce and onion on that
one the Rodeo Burger is a little guy
with onion
the Rodeo Burger Yeehaw onto the chicken
Japan does not have what we call the
original chicken sandwich and I don't
know why Burger King maybe just to set
itself apart the chicken sandwich is
this like sub shape right this is it's
like I'm holding the phone this is great
chicken Junior spicy chicken Junior
let's go spicy
barely registers in the spice meter wait
yeah bks in the US have something called
the chick King sandwich you can get the
sandwich regular or Deluxe you can also
get the sandwich flavor regular or spicy
so here is the regular regular and as
you can see just comes with sauce and
pickles and the chicken you can get a
deluxe and spicy so we went with Deluxe
comes with all these veggies that you
brush off right when you start eating it
and it is got a spicy kind of hue to the
chicken there here is our side menu
let's start with this one we've got hot
dog
it's got such a big sausage
this one is chili beans hot dog
and next we have this little guy
snack chicken
and last we have this one
chili cheese fries
and if you want some veggies you can
order Caesar salad
but my bad I forgot to order
also exclusive to the US are these
chicken fries as you can tell they look
like fries but they're pieces of chicken
no babe
you can get lots apple sauce
jalapeno cheddar bites I've never heard
of these
and now I know why
Burger King in the U.S has two iced
coffee flavors mocha and vanilla
assuming that's the mocha
it's exactly like chocolate milk no oh
the aftertaste is horrible what the hell
that's ridiculous how bad that is and
the vanilla
that is that is so sweet I'm gonna keep
this one
so here is our dessert menus here we
have coffee float a little bit melting
sorry and we have melon soda float
Coke float and Coke Zero float
and here we've got premium Sunday
chocolate and coffee
and here is our chocolate sundae and
strawberry sundae and my favorite is
this apple pie
desserts here in the US you guys have a
Hershey's Sundae Pie
no this one might have uh got a little
roughed up in transit and in the US
Burger King you can also get various
shakes here we have Oreo shake a
chocolate Oreo shake a chocolate shake
and a vanilla shake all right
God that's so good just straight up
chocolate
oh man this is trouble
um
wow Burger King shakes are really good
I'm assuming this is just the straight
Oreo one
oh my God this is fantastic are we all
curious about a chocolate Oreo shake
tastes like Wonder no more
good this one's the best also us Burger
King you can get a soft serve cone I
didn't get it only because we have no
refrigeration unit here and it would
just be a cone with a puddle of ice
cream so Victoria please turn me into a
giant soft serve cone
so here are our drinks let's start with
this one this one is ginger ale and
phantomelon Oolong tea
which is Chinese tea
and orange juice and this one is Earl
Gray iced tea
next we have Darjeeling tea and here is
calpes
which you guys call it Cal Pico in your
country but in Japan we say
I know it sounds like cow piss in
English but if you say calpico to
Japanese people they will never
understand what you're talking about so
in Japan once again we say
repeat after me
very good
first things you can get you can get a
little orange juice guy
and you can also get Capri Sun apple
juice shout out to the pouch Burger King
in the US has Coke products as well but
we have something called a Coke
freestyle machine if you haven't seen
this big machine that has a bunch of
Coca-Cola related beverages you can mix
and match them anyway we can get icy
fruit punch icy pink lemonade Fanta
orange Mellow Yellow Powerade Zero Dr
Pepper barks diet barks you can also get
yourself a fat free milk
there it is sweetened or unsweetened tea
I think I got the Sweden I don't want
any tea tea sucks we also have something
called Frozen Cokes that is this right
here as you can see it's been sitting
for a while starting to separate but we
have frozen Coke you also have a frozen
Fanta Wild Cherry a frozen Phantom blue
raspberry and a frozen strawberry and
lemonade
oh yeah Japan has a exclusive that are
similar but different to that in the US
so for example this is our
plant-based Whopper this burger is made
from 100 soy beans
is
actually delicious I like it
um when it comes to visualism and
veganism they are not that popular in
Japan but gradually especially the
restaurants in Tokyo are offering more
vegan or vegetarian meals because there
is more Japanese people and non-japanese
people who are vegan or vegetarian
compared to other places in Japan but
overall the vegan or vegetarian option
is still Limited in Japan and in the US
we have the impossible Whopper what's
the difference well the impossible
Burger has all these ingredients so as
you can see a lot more
curious
that looks like me
right Texas act like a Whopper I don't
think I would notice the difference
they're covering the lack of meat was
like with that Char flavor they have in
there
oh it was good
in Japan we call this burger crispy
chicken burger
in the US we have the before mentioned
chick King sandwich which comes in
varieties of spicy and or Deluxe for
breakfast our hash brown comes in one
big piece
whereas in the U.S our hash browns come
in little bites and in Japan we have
this cheese bites look at this
and in the US we have eight piece cheesy
tots well
and I'm to the U.S breakfast exclusives
as you can see we have a lot more going
on in our breakfast menu here in the U.S
than Japan has here in the US you can
get your breakfast sandwich and biscuit
or Chris sandwich options Chris sandwich
is of course a croissant sandwich took
those two words put them together for
sandwich so we have bacon egg and cheese
ham egg and cheese
and sausage egg and cheese
we have two breakfast burritos the egg
normas breakfast burrito which I'm
assuming is this one because it is
enormous the breakfast burrito Junior
look at this little guy
French toast sticks who doesn't like
French toast finally pancake platter
with just three pancakes or a pancake
platter with three pancakes and a side
of sausage
[Music]
Burger King in Japan come in three sizes
some more
medium
and large
fries in the U.S at Burger King come in
four sizes value small medium or large
or maybe it's value small medium large
does this look right any of you food
Wars heads would have seen the Burger
King Us versus UK episode where we
uncovered fry Gates two sizes had pretty
much the exact same unit of fries now as
you can see from these I can't tell
which is the value in the small I'm
assuming this is the medium well
unfortunately we cannot do that
amazingly accurate scientific test that
we did in the last episode because the
fries have been compromised they all
came in the same bag and
I think they knew what we were up to and
they purposely dumped all the fries in
the same bag to contaminate the
experiments you got smartest this time
let's weigh the large price to see how
much you actually get
[Music]
151 grams what if we did a thing where
like whatever lands and stays on counts
as counts does that seem like a fair
thing to say
that's really smart what I just did
there I think
it's 195 grams
let's weigh Japan's Whopper
250 grams and let us weigh our Whopper
in the U.S
270. yeah 270 grams it's a pretty cool
surprisingly close
if you're not feeling like having beef
Burger King also had some chicken
options you can order your chicken
nuggets in five pieces and eight pieces
here in the US you can get your nuggets
in sizes of four pieces eight pieces or
16 pieces and it's worth noting that you
can only get the 16 piece online or
through their app and even if you do
they still just give you two eight
pieces I don't know why either
so let's weigh at peace nuggets
130 grams divide by eight equals
16.25 grams per nugget I don't know if
we can get as accurate of a measurement
for something so small so we will use
this guy instead so I'll just do this
and put the scale up here
ah
that is a bad idea eight pieces is that
a hundred and four grams
divided by eight is 13 grams
in Japan we have three drink sizes
small
and medium
and large
in the US we have four drink sizes value
which only comes with a value meal small
medium and large now I want to note that
the US's largest drink size is a hundred
and twelve percent larger than Japan's
largest drink
now what's the biggest meal you can get
in Japan's Burger King over here it's
the king meal
the king meal ranges anywhere from 790
to 990 Yen depending on the burger you
choose it has your choice of an avocado
Whopper double cheeseburger or Whopper
which is the double cheeseburger which
comes with small fries five fish nuggets
medium Coke and apple pie and in the U.S
currently our single biggest menu item
at a Burger King is the 30 Ultimate
Party bundle now you can only order this
party bundle through the BK app and it
includes two Whoppers two double
cheeseburgers two original chicken
sandwiches two eight piece chicken
nuggets four small fries and four small
drinks and it costs
thirty dollars
in Japan a Whopper cheese set it costs
around 890 Yen or seven dollars 80 cents
us whereas in the US the same meal with
a small frying drink is 9.29 or
1059.65 Japanese Yen what about the
medium if you get that the medium frying
medium drink it's 10.29 or
1173.71 Japanese Yen
what about the large
poof hey there it is right in front of
me large fries and drink
11.29 or
1287.78 Japanese Yen
let's look at calories in Japan a
Whopper is 676 calories the calories
aren't too bad but watch out for the
sodium levels one Japan Whopper is 113
of your daily recommended amount of
sodium
too much in the US our Whopper is 667
calories both Whoppers are pretty
comparable in most of the categories but
there's one statistic that really stands
out the salt content the sodium level in
Japan's Whopper is a hundred and twenty
two percent higher than that in the U.S
let's make that a meal a Whopper with
large fries and a large Coke is 1 323
calories and the same meal in the U.S is
1 680 calories so a lot more now a big
portion of the calories actually come
from the large Coke the US's is roughly
182 percent more calories than that in
Japan's let's look at the highest
calorie sandwich at Japan's Burger King
The Double Whopper cheese is here eating
one of these is already half of your
daily calories and a little over your
daily recommended protein the main thing
to watch out for here is the sodium
which is 152 percent of your daily
recommended volume whereas in the US our
highest calorie sandwich is the spicy
chicken deluxe sandwich seen here if
you're worried about your health steer
clear of this one the fat content is 190
percent your daily allowance and the
sodium is over 200 percent of your daily
allowance yikes
as I mentioned earlier the biggest menu
item is the king meal if you get it with
a double bacon cheeseburger the total
calories are 1 329 that's 66 of your
daily calories and of course the 30
Ultimate Party bundle which is 8 903
calories or
445 your daily caloric allowance
[Music]
Burger King in Japan doesn't disclose
the exact ingredients but it does
disclose where the ingredients come from
and where they're finished processing
for example the Whopper beef patties are
sold from Australia New Zealand and
Europe but they are processed in
Australia Japan and Austria Burger King
in the US is pretty vague when it comes
to its ingredients they don't disclose a
comprehensive list anywhere at the end
of 2020 Burger King permanently banned
120 artificial flavors from their menu
including aluminum yellows one through
five BHA and BHT here's the complete
list
it was actually a lot of stuff
good for you guys from calorie count to
portion sizes we wanted to find out all
the differences between Wendy's and
Japan and the US this is food Wars
in Japan our Wendy's hamburgers come in
four sizes Junior single double and
triple
in the US our Burgers come in four sizes
Junior Dave single Dave's double and the
Dave's triple look at the size of this
thing
in Japan
nuggets come in orders of 5 and 10. our
us nuggets come in 4 6 and 10 piece
our windiest drinks come in three sizes
small medium and large and in the US we
also have three drink sizes small medium
you've got to be kidding me look at the
size of this thing this might be 40
ounces you only one way to find out
oh
oh not quite 40. it's a 36 or 37 fluid
ounces of Coca-Cola and how big is a
bladder this looks like more than like I
would normally pee in the morning okay
let's measure our large drink
it measures exactly 500 milliliters
our wind is fries come in two sizes
small and medium
our fries come in four sizes Junior
small
medium
large let's wear largest
roughly a hundred and eighty
it weighs 135 grams Japan's chili comes
in two sizes medium and large
and the us our chili comes in two sizes
small and large lettuce weigh the
largest now including the paper cup
430 grams let's weigh our large chili
265 grams
in Japan I went into Burger USA double
is 730 Yen or 6.38 us our us Dave's
double goes for 5.99 or around 685
Japanese Yen that's a 6.16 decrease in
price in the US let's make it a meal in
Japan if you get your burger as I said
it includes a small fries and a
three-piece nuggets and a drink it costs
around 440 Yen more our meals only
include fries and drink so a small
Dave's double meal and I threw in a four
piece because we don't have a three
piece works out to
10.98 that's an 8.12 increase cost in
the US mind you we did get an extra
nugget speaking of nuggets in Japan 10
piece nugget is 510 Yen which breaks
down to 51 Yen per nugget in the US a 10
piece nugget is 429 which makes it per
nugget around 43 cents so per nugget
average the US is paying 8 0.11 percent
less abeconero double in Japan is 850
Yen or 7.43 cents in the US you get that
same Baconator for 7.49 or 857 Japanese
Yen so close only at 0.82 increase
here is everything you can get at the
Wendy's in Japan you cannot get in the
US
and here's everything at the US Wendy's
you can't get in Japan one thing I want
to point out is that in Japan Wendy's is
known as Wendy's first kitchen first
kitchen is a Japanese fast food chain
then it was acquired by Wendy's in 2016
and became a hybrid of Wendy's and first
kitchens and venues and we call them
King which is the abbreviation of first
Kitchen in a Japanese way it's like
first kitchen sofa and kitchens Ki and
and say repeat after me
King
got it buddy very good
very good so here are our Japan's
exclusive Burgers so this one is bacon
Mushroom Melt and this one is just
mushroom milk we have Wendy's back on
neck Burger we also have Wendy's cheese
bacon egg burger and this sauce
tartar sauce
um everybody is curious what this is
this one is Wild Rock it's got no buns
it's got two beef patties I think I
should try this one
this mate itself has a good taste and
some kind of like peppery flavor but
it's a little bit dry I wouldn't get
this again and last things we have
Junior teriyaki burger and we have
Junior Teriyaki cheeseburger
the big bacon cheeseburger the big bacon
double
look at this yep one two three the big
bacon triple I mean I don't know what
what what angle is best to look at this
at and then we got big Bacons on the
fancy bread this must be the big Bacon's
Classics is this looks like a big bacon
looks like shredded cheese and stuff on
this everything's bacon something with
these guys at this point it's just like
how many slabs of meat do you want on
your bacon sandwich two things you can
get at a Wendy's in the U.S Kaneka in
Japan are just the junior burger and the
junior cheeseburger look at this little
guy look at this literally every fast
food burger place has a version of this
chicken
ah
the Asiago chicken sandwiches we got the
Asiago chicken ranch classic Club I said
that in the wrong order but you get what
I mean probably this one this is the
fried Asiago club with bacon and then
there is the spicy which I'm assuming is
this one
and then they got
the grilled
this is pretty good
don't like Asiago when is as you covered
so many chicken sandwiches at Wendy's
that of course are not asiagoed this is
the grilled chicken sandwich as you can
see it is grilled and then we have the
grilled chicken big bacon man they got
they must have gotten some deal on on
bacon for Wendy's everything's got bacon
in it I'm gonna go ahead and assume this
is the big bacon fried chicken sandwich
because it has bacon on it so the spicy
big bacon cheddar chicken in Japan our
Wendy's have pasta which were originally
on the first Kitchen menu so here we
have Ramen style soy cream pasta with
spinach and ham expires
2023 January 20th Joe I'll keep this for
you now that guy you can go ahead and
throw that out
and next we have Ramen style tan tan
soup pasta with spinach and ham so it's
kind of like a spicy chili flavored soup
with miso and pork mince tantan soup and
Tanta Ramen are very popular in Japan
tomato sauce pasta with mozzarella
and bacon all right next we have
beef chick meat cream spaghetti
plastic
next we have carbonara spaghetti
carbonara carbonara
okay
it's got bacon and this creamy
carbonara sauce
last thing I have is spicy cuddle
spaghetti so spicy Cod roll in Japanese
is men Taiko and Men Taiko spaghetti is
also very popular in Japan unfortunately
some Americans I know don't like men
Taiko so much because of the texture and
smell but for me men Taiko it's super
delicious uh it's been a while
since I got this one it's been like
three hours it
Joe
tried it out I appreciate the offer
George but you can go ahead and finish
that because it looks disgusting
we got salads over here on this end the
first one looks like we got the parmesan
Caesar salad comes with of course Caesar
dressing and what looks to be Parmesan
crisps this next salad is ridiculous
we're gonna go ahead and put quotes
around Salad Wendy's has a taco salad
that comes with tortilla chips sour
cream signature salsa and that wasn't
enough chili
before we continue you confirm that the
taco salad supposed to have chili on it
they told you that chips all around here
I can't believe this this is so gross
signature salsa then chili oh it smells
so bad
oh God
I'm just this is just like eating chili
with tortilla chips they said there's
some salt I'm just pushing this around
and then an egg salad the Southwest
avocado salad
oh my God there's bacon on it that's
weird that was in Dave Thomas's obituary
I want everything to be covered in bacon
but yeah chicken avocado bacon cheese
and some sauce this makes sense and the
last salad
Apple pecan salad that smells oh because
it's like a blue cheese on it roasted
pecan bits pomegranate vinaigrette
apples are nice it's kind of nice to get
a little bit of actual like fruits
something nutritious while doing this
it's like my body's like what is this
so here are our Japan style menu we have
a few flavor options for fries so we
have happy butter flavor fries
puppy butter flavor
has just subtle buttery flavor
burnt butter soy sauce flavor rip it up
I don't know what's going on here but
it's pretty good much better than this
Savory steamed potato butter it gets
quite strong buttery flavor definitely I
prefer this one than the happy butter
flavor this is not happy this one is
chicken consomme flavor mmm
this is the best fries I've ever had in
my life now I'm gonna introduce you this
spicy chicken
breast
when is in the US also has baked
potatoes see what we got of course
there's your
regular and this one oh yeah this one's
got like chives and stuff in it if I was
to stop here you would go wow what a
tasteful selection of healthy potatoes
but of course we don't stop here we move
on to Absolute baked potato Madness ah
number one
cheese baked potato drown this thing in
cheese it's like it's like ooh it's like
cake to the side look
[Music]
the chili and cheese baked potato
yeah if you are like me you're wondering
yourself something's missing something
is missing from this potato menu Yuli
can you guess what that is the bacon
cheese baked potato I think a big piece
of bake on this one too oh
you can get spicy chicken nuggets yes
Siri Bob
season potatoes
all right some fruit finally made the
menu apple slices it wouldn't be a
Wendy's category without the Baconator
fries we need the bacon meter in this
episode last of the sides
oh yeah oatmeal bar looks like a cliff
bar
well it's actually pretty good
so here are our Japan's exclusive drinks
we have tapioca Royale milk tea with
brown sugar and tapioca milk with brown
sugar
tornado
um
this is amazing
simply amazing I love this so here are
our other drinks we have Pepsi orange
juice and ginger ale lemonade and melon
soda
PhD and iced tea ice matcha and this one
is ice cocoa
so here we have our hot drinks we have
Darjeeling tea
and we have coffee mocha
and we have peachyti
um
I like this and we have coffee latte and
cocoa and matcha this is matcha but it
looks like water from 100 years ago
our Wendy's has Frosty chinos which I'm
assuming are frosties meat Frappuccinos
Frosty chinos but it does not appear
that there's frosties in this they have
two flavors vanilla and chocolate
assuming this is the vanilla
Wendy's just smart on this one it isn't
that it isn't that sweet I was expecting
it to be like undrinkable but it's
actually kind of nice all right this one
is the chocolate
yeah also
it's a nice flavor because the Frosted
chinos you know what that means a
Wendy's doing also good oh yeah frosties
they don't have these in Japan I feel
like this is the staple menu item
I love this so much
fantastic that's fantastic that's
fantastic gotta go for the chocolate
don't buy the final minute spoon I'm
just going to taste here it's great
the prices are great it's like a
milkshake but it's super thick and
delicious Japan you want this yeah thick
it is thick in Japan we have floats
instead of frosties we have cork float
and melon soda float
Japan has an exclusive breakfast
sandwich
it's called the breakfast sandwich
it's got tomato lettuce and I believe
this is beef or pork patties
okay whereas Japan has one exclusive
breakfast sandwich we have way more like
all the fast food here in America we
take our breakfast very seriously you
can get yourself a maple bacon croissant
it looks like it's a chicken sandwich
that of course has bacon and maple syrup
on the croissant uh we have what just
appears to be the bacon biscuit bacon
egg
cheese in the incredibly dry biscuits
bacon croissants I don't know about this
one moving on to the sausage zone of the
Wendy's breakfast this is the special
sausage biscuit no no no no no no no
here's what I hate about this pick a
dryer thing to have for breakfast I feel
like it'd be impossible to swallow a
bite of this you're gonna choke on it
here we go see this is what I'm talking
about they might have gotten this
backwards this is actually the better
sausage one this at least has a better
chance of not getting stuck in your
throat the sausage croissants
also has egg thank you they have a few
things that are honey butter based I am
so glad that fast food places are
introducing honey to the breakfast menu
I think maybe it's to do with the fact
that chicken sandwiches have become so
popular first one we got here is the
honey butter biscuit
hey it's just a biscuit with honey
butter I mean yeah I'll have this
anytime I'll have this anytime this one
has some f to it it's the hot honey
biscuit
a little chicken on there yep
I really like that
this is the special chicken croissants
so here are our desserts so here we have
melodoto are maritoto style pastries
which are popular in Rome and Japan as
well made with melon bread so melon
bread is a type of sweet Japanese bread
which has a sugar cookie crust on the
surface but what's funny is that it
doesn't have a melon flavor I don't
the reason it's called melon bread is
that it just looks like melon does it
look like melon
it does in Japan
and this time first kitchen made a
maritotso using melon bread and
Mascarpone cheese whipped cream and it's
called melaton
so here we have melodoto Tiramisu and
melod
plain so actually yesterday was my
birthday February 18th hey it's your
birthday happy birthday George thank you
for your message thank you so this is my
birthday
all right so let's give it a shot best
birthday present ever
this is so good
I can't stop eating this
so Wendy's in Japan has a Japanese
traditional Suite since it has been a
collaboration with first kitchen so we
have shiratama cream Zentai
so it has three main ingredients ice
cream and sweet red beans and the
shiratama which is kind of like a Mochi
rice cake and my grandma likes this type
of
this is for you my grandma and also we
have
mini pancakes
in the US we will have two exclusive
desserts in both cookies that's no
disrespect to cookies cookies are great
but one of those fun like Italian ice
cream sandwiches they have anyway you
get two cookies here in the U.S a
chocolate chunk cookie and a sugar
cookie
[Music]
our Wendy's double burger is 578
calories and 29 of your daily
recommended amount and 60 of the
recommended daily sodium our double
burger the Dave's double isn't much
better ours is 850 calories and way more
fat over 70 percent but less sodium just
a bit over half of the daily amount
still not great make the meal in Japan
and that increases the calories to 1089
that's 55 of your daily recommended
calorie intake
and if they get a combo here we chose
the small and took a few sips that's 440
more calories bringing the total to 1
290 or 64.5 percent of your daily
allowance in Japan the single menu item
with the most calories is The Edge piece
Fried Chicken pack which contains
4018 calories 201 of your daily calories
in the US our single biggest calorie
menu item is the feed the fam deal a fam
yeah right this is all for you it is two
spicy chicken sandwiches two junior
bacon cheeseburgers and for a small
fries total 2 780 calories which is a
hundred and thirty nine percent of your
daily intake
Japan's Wendy's doesn't disclose their
ingredients list
why Japan the US sure does now is there
anything we should be looking out for of
course there is let's start with sodium
nitrate which is found in the
baconator's Applewood smoked bacon
sodium nitrate is a chemical that is
used to cure meats and gives meat that
appealing pink color perfect for bacon
also get this it's super toxic it is
restricted for purchase online people
have accidentally eaten too much of it
and died it's also been used in
homicides yikes sodium nitrate is on a
list of Japan's designated food
additives but our Wendy's gets its bacon
imported from Denmark where it isn't bad
but being reduced in use our American
cheese contains lecithin common
emulsifier that according to one
academic a worrisome number of
scientific Studies have suggested that
too much of it can promote depression
the pickles contain polysorbate 80 this
is commonly used as an emulsifier in
foods but pickles tends to be used as a
solubilizer not how that's pronounced
sorry which helps other ingredients in
the brine fully dissolve Studies have
suggested it can cause colon cancer in
mice not fantastic there is no info on
Wendy's website of where the pickles
come from but we want to point out that
polysorbate 80 is on Japan's list of
designated additives and therefore is
permitted to be used in Japan
from Toleration to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between dominoes in Japan and the US
this is food Wars
[Music]
in Japan Domino's Pizzas come in three
sizes our Domino's Pizza comes in four
sizes so this one is medium which is cut
into Edge slices over here on this end
you got the small that's 10 inch pizza
and here's regular which is also cut
into Edge slices next up is our medium
that's a 12 inch pizza
and this one is large this one is cut
into 12 slices then we move to our large
14 inches
and finally the extra large which is 16
inches look at all that grease
[Music]
a Domino's large plain pizza has a 33
centimeters diameter or an
855.3 square centimeters area and cost 2
000 yen so breaking it down our pizza is
2.33 Yen per square inch or about 2
cents now take our large this is a 14
inch pizza also a 35.56 centimeter pizza
and it has a surface area of
993.1 square centimeters that's 1.4
cents per square inch or 1.62 Japanese
Yen but what gives you the most food for
your money so here is a large plain
slice with a pan crust and of course
another with Hannah toss the crust let's
wear both right now and see which is
more so first let's weigh pancrest
51 grams and hand tossed crust
it weighs 49 grams
and we will do the same I want to note
that right now in America you can only
get the pan dominoes in a medium size
same exact experiment only I'm doing two
medium pizzas medium pan slice medium
hand tossed slice so this is the hand
toss slice and it weighs
a smidge over 75 we'll go 76. the pan
that goes in there too
110 grams
making the difference this amount
I'm not doing math
in Japan we have seven different craft
options number one we have pan
and number two we have hand tossed
and number three we have Ultra crispy
it's like a cracker
number four we have cheese burst where a
string cheese is placed around the edge
of a crust and sprinkled with consomme
parmesan seasoning
number five we have the cheese and roll
it's got mozzarella cheese in the crust
and number six we have mile filet or mil
foi
mil fail in Japanese we say you so this
one is Miro for you Pizza which has two
layers of grass with Camembert mixed
cheese in between
[Music]
French people please correct my
pronunciation
number seven the last one we have the
triple Mill pay it's got three layers of
crass with cheese in between
wow in the U.S we have only five crust
options I realize there's four pieces in
front of me let me explain one crust
option you can get here and it's a small
only is the gluten free crust I don't
know
how bread
is gluten-free
but we figured it out
we also have the hand tossed
which is more of a standard pillowy I
mean this might just like standard delt
is what we think a pizza looks like this
is the pan look how thick that is man
that's like triple the dough thickness
good on you for the pan now you can get
this in the medium only we also have a
crunchy thin crust and we have so many
pieces here to be honest I don't know
which one it is so when it just comes up
in the video I'll show it off but
imagine a crunchy thin pizza oddly
enough we also have something called the
Brooklyn style pizza this is reserved
for large and extra large pizzas only
and this is a Brooklyn style right here
extra large obviously isn't crispy
because it's sagging this is really thin
here's everything you can get into
Japanese dominoes that you cannot get in
the US here's everything you can get at
a U.S Domino's you cannot get in Japan
so everyone look at this this is a
limited time offer Pizza it's called the
best 34. look at this lid it's
disgusting don't look at me don't look
at me so this one has all 34 dominoes
toppings like teriyak chicken mayo
spinach tomato shrimp this is huge
it's like my baby
the New Yorker style pizza is similar to
the Brooklyn XL option you can get in
America but only in Japan you can get
the Quattro New Yorker it's a 16 inch
pizza with each New Yorker topping style
covering a quarter of the pizza so one
quarter is pepperoni and one is cheese
and one is pepperoni and sausage and one
is ham and mushroom so here we have
Nippon favorite series Nippon or nihong
means Japan in Japanese so these pizzas
feature Japanese ingredients this one
charcoal grills teriyak chicken it's got
teriyaki chicken teriyaki sauce spinach
mayonnaise and corn next we have
Hokkaido three cheeses so Hokkaido is
the Northern Ireland refactor in Japan
and it's famous for its cheese it's got
a hokkaida gouda cheese Hokkaido cheddar
cheese and Hokkaido Camembert and
Celeste asparagus we have spicy mayo and
mochi it's got Mochi rice cake and corn
pork sausage and sliced asparagus and
Korean seaweed Flakes and last one we've
got charcoal grilled beef and spinach
and mushrooms
um
oh
this beef is so tender and it's got so
much like charcoal flavor
which makes this amazing I love this so
many exclusive pizzas here at the US
dominoes I don't know where to begin so
I'll just start with this one that I'm
holding this is the Cali chicken bacon
ranch I don't know what makes a
California in e or Cali but it
definitely has chicken and bacon and
ranch and it's big
thank you very much all right
chicken taco pizza
oh yeah
Taco spices to it good job on this one
next one the cheeseburger pizza
um
yeah oh my God
I'm gonna say something crazy this
tastes exactly like a McDonald's
cheeseburger even has like the oniony
and the ketchupy taste
wow
that is a surprise
I thought this one's gonna be bad it's
actually pretty good the extravaganza
it says pepperoni sausage
ham
mushrooms
black olives green peppers this is the
meatza which I'm assuming is just a lot
of meats I'm seeing sausage I'm seeing
pepperoni and maybe hamburger
yeah I'll put this in the good pile up
with this one Philly cheese steak oh no
in some weird way I'm blaming you for
this since you handed this to me this is
your fault
look at this nightmare meat somewhere on
here I'm also seeing green peppers oh
look look it's like it's like
look at that it's like stuck to the Box
no
buffalo chicken okay okay this is more
my speed chicken you know not tomato
sauce like a white sauce good call
mmm
this isn't Buffalo enough the capital of
the great state of New York needs to be
better represented in this pizza the
capital of New York is Buffalo correct
no we got the Memphis barbecue chicken
love Memphis love barbecue love chicken
yeah the key thing here is the barbecue
sauce I don't know what is in it but man
that's really good Memphis
capital is a great state of Tennessee
everyone here is the ultra cheese New
Yorker
it's got one kilogram of cheese or 2.2
pounds OMG
look how thick this tooth is
go
go home it weighs 180 grams
180 times 8 equals
1440 grams in total so here are other
Japanese specialty pizzas so here we
have Quattro meet Max
cesco charcoal grilled teriyak chicken
and charcoal grilled beef and Giga meat
and dorio galbi it's like Korean style
like beef pizza and next we have seafood
special
this part and this part is shrimp
mayonnaise so this part it's got shrimp
octopus mussels Little Neck clumps mock
drawer clumps green peppers and cherry
tomatoes next we've got garlic master
looks so spicy garlic and pork sausage
and pancetta and this part is got
jalapeno obviously it's picante
pepperoni and Italian sausage and onions
and look at this huge thing
means potato in Japanese it's got potato
and pork sausage and a lot of mayo our
us dominoes has sandwiches and pasta I
was not a fan of the Philly cheese steak
pizza but let's see what the Philly
cheesesteak tastes like in
its native form of sandwich
better than the pizza
also the US dominoes you can get a
buffalo chicken sandwich a chicken
habanero sandwich the Mediterranean
veggie no thanks a chicken bacon ranch
an Italian sandwich and of course the
chicken parm sandwich our Domino's has
four pastas to choose from I only got
two the chicken alfredo and the Italian
sausage marinara you can also get a
chicken carbonara and a pasta primavera
I've just been informed I have to eat
this
a strong flavor on this I would skip the
pasta and Domino's personally the top of
this thing is like baked on see how big
this is like come on it's like Chef
Ramsay or just about oh come on
don't you in the US we have a few
chicken options you can't get in Japan
yes Japan has wings but they don't have
these flavors visually I can see why
first flavor we got here is the garlic
parmesan at Domino's what are you doing
next one we got I'm assuming this is the
honey barbecue but these drizzles what
do you guys doing drizzling man just
toss it toss it in the sauce nobody
wants a drizzle
oh wait a second
this is a sweet mango habanero I wasn't
expecting that heat
[Music]
oh man
very good these are
why did you do this why did you do this
toss it in the sauce why'd you squirt it
on here like as an afterthought honey
barbecue right is this not nuts this is
nuts right they did it like this
Uncle Charles
so Domino's also does their wings in
boneless flavors they have obviously
those three and you can also get these
two other ones and I see we have a
crispy bacon and tomato and this one
must be the spicy jalapeno pineapple
whoa what
hell yeah all right
get that bee real fast there it goes
I know you should hear
your audible gasps are warranted I don't
know what this
what am I supposed to do with this
oh that's what I'm looking forward to
Julie we got the food less than an hour
ago
I don't think an hour
as unrealistic for food to sit I think
you guys got to put some more chemicals
in your cheese to keep it goopy or
hunger oh I got some pineapple and I got
some jalapeno then I got some chicken
let's check it out
yeah
overall
everything here tastes pretty good
presentation you gotta work on that in
Japan we don't have boneless wings but
we have Japanese Fried Chicken which is
called karage it kind of looks like
American boneless wings
I love karage
and also we have chicken nuggets both
come in 4 8 and 12 pieces our dominoes
has Breads and oven baked tips let's
review the breads first shall we over
here we have Parmesan bread twists and
garlic bread twists I know that because
of their totally Twisted shapes they
also have Parmesan bread bites that were
currently unavailable
whoa oh
these are very good
parmesan we go
that is not as good but still pretty
good
I mean it's bread and cheese and oil
right you guys Daven is something called
stuffed cheesy bread you hear stuff
cheesy bread with either spinach and
Vera or bacon and jalapenos take a while
to guess which one I chose
the heart oh God
this thing is especially greasy
for whatever reason
ah Domino's didn't stop there Domino's
has something called dips
what it appears to be
is a giant dish of melted cheese and you
can get it in cheesy marinara or five
cheese what are we doing dominoes
what is this come on guys
so this is the marinara one I'm assuming
a pizza without the bread right this
these dips are literally zapping my will
to live yes please don't ever get
that's the whole bowl of cheese you eat
why would oh look at the oil in this too
you went in here just gagged can I even
dip it
oh whoa
I don't know one of the five cheeses is
in here like which five
[Music]
so here are Japanese exclusive side of
menu items let's start with this one
we've got oven baked potato wedges
this one is plain consoleme
chili garlic
and this one is butter
and next we have cheese sticks
shrimp popcorn
it comes with this tartar sauce here we
have torregi salad we've got Korean
style seaweed Flakes and tragic
the turkey is like Korean style like
sesame oil dressing and
fresh salad in the package
so here we have corn potage clam chowder
minestrone black chili
you've seen these before it is the
Domino's marbled cookie brownies
liquid sugar oh yeah you can also get
these cinnamon bread twists lastly
another dip I swear to God
if there's cheese in this I'm walking
out of here and I'm never coming back
baked apple dips and I'm assuming you
dip these into this I'm not gonna so
here are other desserts we have mini
pancakes
heart-shaped Fonda chocolate
and here we have egg custard tart I have
never tried this one before
this is so good
so flaky
so this one is apple pie
and next we have custard pie
lastly
of the sodas you can get in the U.S
can't get in Japan get yourself Fanta
orange and Sprites
so we have Coke Zero it's supposed to be
zero but they gave us just normal Coke
next we have ginger ale
Canada Dry Canada is an amazing country
a
cool orange juice
and here is
like Japanese Blended tea and last one
we've got
Georgia Japan Kraft cafe latte Georgia
Japan
sounds like George Japan
I'd like to be sponsored by you let me
try this
it's got a lot of milk and sugar in it I
gotta be honest it's not my taste
take two
I really love this please give me a
sponsorship
a Japanese had a toaster Pizza is 130
calories per slice or 1560 calories for
the full Pizza
in the US a large hand tossed pizza
slice is 280 calories which makes the
entire Pizza 2
240 calories a large big pepperoni had a
toast slice is 335 calories per slice or
4020 calories for the entire Pizza our
large pepperoni is 370 calories per
slice which makes the entire Pie 2 960
calories Japan's most calorific Pizza is
the ultra cheese New Yorker size one
slice is 478 calories that's
3827 for the full Pizza
ah
uh our U.S Domino's Pizza with the most
calories is the Cali chicken bacon ranch
this is an XL of said pizza one slice
560 calories and that makes the full pie
3 360 calories our alert is playing
Pizza has 1 620 calories total our large
cheese is 2 240 calories that's a 38.2
percent increase our large big pepperoni
is
2680 calories over 34 of your daily
recommended calorie intake
333 of your daily sodium
too many tasty calories ours is 2 960
calories 48 over your daily recommended
amount but somehow ours has less sodium
only
299 of your daily sodium
in October of last year a study found
detectable amounts of phthalates a
plastic softener and common menu items
from large fast food chains including
Domino's
the study analyzed 64 food samples from
several popular fast food chains and
found phthalites dnbp and dehp and a
majority of the items USA Today reported
that food containing meat such as
chicken burritos and cheeseburgers had
higher levels of the chemical study
while cheese pizza had the lowest levels
okay so that's good news for dominoes I
guess the study goes down to say that
food handling gloves contain replacement
plasticizers which may be the source of
food contamination sounds to me like an
easy fix just prepare the food without
gloves Japan has a ban on dehp in food
handling Globes gooder news if you're a
fan of food Wars in southern U.S versus
UK Domino's episode we highlighted BHA
and BHT in the U.S pepperoni well on the
stewardship page on Domino's website
they have stated we have eliminated a
long list of ingredients from all of our
core products including BHA and BHT and
pho's as well as trans fats from core
Pizza products which is fantastic news I
clearly was going to eat it anyway but
thank you regardless
from a calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Porky in Japan and the US this
is food Wars
[Music]
in Japan our pocket comes in a 72 gram
box which contains two pockets
and online pack
our pockets come in basically three
sizes the 1.14 ounce box the 2.47 ounce
box and the 4.13
ounce
boxy bag but our strawberry flavored box
is smaller than this chocolate box this
is a 3.81 ounce box which is 0.32 ounces
smaller than this one largest box bag is
this the cookies and cream flavor which
is
4.57 ounces or 0.44 grams larger than
the chocolate box one Theory my theory
is that the pocket boxes contain a
specific number of Pocky sticks and each
Pocky is a different weight based on the
flavor coating so we're gonna weigh each
Pocky individually to see if this is
true all right chocolate first so seven
of these
are 13 grams can someone write that down
strawberry seven is
13 grams was that what their version was
okay
cookies and cream cookies and cream
seven of them are 18 grams of all the
cookies and cream ones are definitely a
lot heavier a lot heavier
um so let's see how many palki are in a
box
nip some
[Music]
32 33
34 34 Pocky in total so one pocket has
17 Pocky and another one also has 70
hockey let's see how many pockets are in
this box
oh man
is this normal
I think I could count them like do you
want to get like a close-up on on there
before so one two three those are broken
ones
30 31 32 33 34 35 36
you know how everyone was complaining
about how I eat uh Kit Kats in the
KitKat episode
um
here's all the pakis that are native to
the us that are not in Japan and here
are all the pakis native to Japan
cookies and cream
cookies and cream not a solid block so
that's good
yeah yeah
um I like those this looks like fun Yuli
chocolate banana have you had these
before you have
yeah
that banana flavor hits like right away
oh no
matching green tea any food Wars heads
watching now
Joe does not like matcha
smells like a freshly cut lawn
yeah
there's also a crunchy strawberry flavor
you can get here in the U.S but I was
not able to get my hands on it by the
time of filming this episode so
here's just regular strawberry
oh another
solid block yeah
well good
put me in jail for crimes against
monkeys
George's energy
let's go all right let's start with this
one we have Pocky luxury milk chocolate
is it Pokey you look like corn dog
what happened to you
it's got milk and fermented butter
flavor and we have another corn dog it's
a almond milk flavor foreign
yes strong almond milk flavor I prefer
this one the milk chocolate or both are
so short you should be longer
you too we have this ultra thin potty
oh
this part's so thin
we have tasty why is it tasty oh
fermented butter is used for this stick
boom
it's got just a little bit of butter
flavor I still prefer this one this corn
dog
almond Crush
it's a little bit different look at the
pockets
yeah obviously it's got almonds
okey-dokey Pokey itadakimasu
I love this
I love this hmm it's got Pocky chocolate
coconut oh this one is also
this style of pockets
oh
it's pretty similar with this one almond
Crush
yeah obviously it's got coconut flavor
and also it's got a little bit of
saltiness it's not my case
strawberry chocolate Pocky
oh
ah right after you buy this you get some
sweetness but after that you get
sourness it smells so strong
I can smell it from here
cocoa powder Pocky and it says you can
only get this in winter season oh yeah
look at this it's got cocoa powder
we've got the cutest Pocky ever cherry
heart-shaped hockey
oh look at this heart is in there how
cute and this part Cherry chocolate is
so awesome
you get strong cherry flavor we've also
got blueberry heart-shaped chocolate
Pocky
look at this
so blue this color doesn't make me want
to eat this
but let's try
it
[Music]
so sour
but look at this heart-shaped Pocky
not for me
this is what I've been waiting for
Sakura matcha
cherry blossom cherry blossom matcha
taste
oh
look at this
so it's got matcha chocolate and this
steak is
pink
this is so japanesey Pocky just sweet
matcha the feeling of spring has come to
my life
spring is here in my body
[Music]
everybody's curious what fits
off Mega minoruvi
what does it mean
I don't even know
anyway so it says
like goddess
Ruby
in English it says Amber kind of like
Stone fossil Jewel it says it goes well
with red wine interesting
it looks like regular chocolate Pocky
full
what is this
this test itself is like berries this
one goes well with whiskey
it's pretty close to dark chocolate it's
bitter in Japan we have this called
kuboso extra fine Pocky which are
roughly half a thickness of a regular
chocolate Pocky and in the US ours are
called the ultra slim I got a new
digital scale what I'm gonna do is weigh
a regular chocolate Pocky
2.13 grams
to ultra thin hockey so it weighs 1.52
grams
thinner that's it
here's a big boy
here's the thing
is this able to do this okay like get
out of the way so just the white
background 23 24 25 and there's another
bag in here so 50 per box okay so 50
instead of 36. seven regular pockies are
13 grams let's see how many slim ones we
need to get to 13 grams five six seven
eight and a half eight and a half slim
ones are the same as seven regular ones
is that that much Slimmer I guess that's
Slimmer does anyone think that like
there's like not significant enough to
be a selling point Pocky adjusts its
sweetness for different countries not
surprisingly the US ones are meant to be
sweeter I'm gonna do a taste test side
by side they've got the American ones
here's the Japanese one and we're gonna
see just how different they taste I'm
worried that these are also going to be
a
a pocket popsicle oh no okay
these there's only Japanese ones I could
find obviously they're bigger I don't
know if this is the norm
in the Baseline food
yeah it's noticeably different
they taste identical but ours has
like a sweet aftertaste I like I like
the Japanese ones much better sapaki is
in the Guinness World Records three
times it's the largest chocolate coated
biscuits brand has the most mentions of
a brand name on Twitter in 24 hours
which was three million seven hundred
ten thousand forty four times
and finally what's part of the most
people opening packaged food online
simultaneously with 143 people 143
people that's it that doesn't seem like
that many I feel like I've been on Zoom
work calls with 143 people in it right
it would have been literally one email
to set that up I can do
[Laughter]
now I got more than 200 George's clothes
right here simultaneously three two one
[Applause]
now I broke the Guinness World Records
so November 11th is known as a Pokemon
or Pokemon in Japan
this date was chosen because a party is
shifted like a one at November 11th
visually looks like 4 Pocky and also
prints are included in this day November
11th which is the pretzel version of
Pocky and in Japan you can get them in
flavors like salad ripe tomato sweet
potato and roasted bread flavor in the
US we also have pretz and we get these
fun flavors like sweet corn fun and
pizza oh God
it's not gonna add it
nope I mean yeah it tastes like
corn why though what is the demand for
corn flavored
sticks ah
besides pizza anything flavored like
pizza is terrible even Pizza combos
aren't very good
no
I mean it's up there with like croutons
does anyone grab a handful of croutons
on the go and we're just eating a box of
croutons like these probably would be
good on something
in Japan our chocolate pocket box for
100 grams has 506 calories adjusted for
the box size 72 grams the package
contains
364.3 calories
and let's break it down even further to
per party one poke contains on average
11.38 calories
a US chocolate pocket box contains 340
calories just a little bit less than a
Japanese box but note there is a 2 gram
difference now here at Food Wars we
thrive on scientific accuracy so let's
break it down per Pocky one U.S Pocky is
9.444444444444444444 calories
the highest calorie Park in Japan is to
be determined we email the customer
service but we didn't get their response
what are you doing hurry up but I guess
the Sparky is the most calorific hockey
it's 196 calories
so should be
because it's got a lot of butter in it
the U.S Pocky with the most calories is
the cookies and cream it contains total
630 calories there's no question I can
murder this whole box in one setting 630
calories that's nothing that's that's
like kind of reassuring like wow only
630 found my breakfast
[Music]
Japan poke contains these ingredients
wheat flour sugar cacao mess vegetable
oils whole milk powder shortening malt
extract starch salt yeast cocoa powder
butter emulsifier flavoring leavening
agent another coloring and mineral salt
any U.S pocket contains wheat flour
sugar chocolate liqueur blend of
vegetable oils that blend being
sunflower oil palm oil whole milk powder
vegetable oil shortening which is palm
oil hydrogenated palm oil cocoa butter
salt artificial flavors yeast soy
lecithin leavings sodium bicarbonate
mono and diglycerides of fatty acids
wink
in Japan our Pocky contains malt extract
which is sometimes used as a replacement
for sugar in baking it contains lots of
maltose a type of sugar which actually
has a higher glycemic index value than
normal sucrose so it's a surprise that
American Pocky are supposed to be
sweeter there are actually differences
in the types of cocoa used if you've
watched the Us versus UK Snickers
episode you know that American chocolate
is not so great in the US our pockies
are made with chocolate liqueur and
cocoa butter chocolate liqueur is just
coca that's been processed into
semi-solid form and is actually around
50 cocoa butter itself the trouble is
for an American product to be classified
as milk chocolate only needs to contain
around 10 percent of chocolate liqueur
and the rest can be made up of sugars
and various ingredients
in Japan the rules are different
depending on the type of product milk
chocolate material must contain at least
21 cocoa content double the required
amount in America so our chocolate has
more chocolate are you jealous of us
come to Japan
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between 7-Eleven and Japan and the US
this is food worries
in Japan our coffee is coming very small
medium and large and extra large if
you're getting coffee why not grab a
chocolate donut
our 7-Eleven drinks come in sizes of 200
milliliters full 150 milliliters and one
liter and 1.5 liters I'm sorry I
couldn't get it
in the US we have big gulps self-service
fountain drink four sodas and they come
in these four sizes medium large extra
large double extra so I want to see how
much the biggest size cup I could get at
the 7-Eleven is and to do that I will
need hang on
just past 40. it's exactly 48 ounces
that's hardly double extra I'll round it
up because of this section here I'll
round it up to 50. 7-Eleven also at one
point offered a size that was even
bigger called the team Gump which again
according to them was 128 fluid ounces
for your team because who doesn't like
to after a softball game going to
7-Eleven get a team Gulp and 10 straws
you know just kick it with the with the
boys right come on team yeah right
that's for one person don't be
ridiculous
[Music]
here are many many many
7-Eleven items you can get in the U.S
you can't get in Japan and here are
remaining with the 7-Eleven items
exclusive
Japan puts the convenience in the
convenience store we call it which is
the abbreviation of the convenience
store and it makes our life a lot easier
for example office workers rely on
stores like 7-Eleven for food and drink
to keep them happy so that they can be
productive at work
and for students they tend to buy juices
and snacks and hot foods insta noodles
you know and when I was a kid I would
often eat like hot foods and instant
noodles with my friends and with my
ex-girlfriends
7-Eleven memories
[Music]
and for families there is pretty much
every daily essential they may need and
also you can pay your bills get tickets
reservations for music and sports
7-Eleven even has its own bank and ATMs
no matter where you go especially in big
cities like Tokyo you can find more than
one company on every block yeah it's a
bit different here in the US I do
frequent 7-Eleven and it's not bad but
the vibe is more kind of like get the
thing you need and go uh the food is
usually pretty Hit or Miss usually Miss
in my experience uh the hot food looks
like it's been sitting out for a while
so I usually don't get it so if there
are way too many items exclusive to
Japan for us to buy for one episode so I
have curated some of my favorites for
you guys this is still a ton of food so
here we have Japanese onigiri
this one is plum tuna mayonnaise shrimp
and mayonnaise men daiko which is spicy
called raw I picked these onigiri's from
the back because onigiri in the back are
fresh of all time and let me show you
how to open this one just pull this over
till here
like this
so that you can have the dried you know
seaweed
mess
a little bit sweet a little bit of sour
so here is our Sushi look at this huge
salmon sushi
ah
gorgeous gorgeous sushi itarakimasu oh
my God this is so delicious
[Music]
we got this long natural
personally I love Naruto but even
Japanese people
50 of them like it 50 of them don't like
it this is an acquired taste
eister
so after this sticky and smelly natural
I've got sushi rolls special package so
when it comes to this one it's called
it has rice inside and the skin is like
a sweet tough skin
um
[Music]
this is so good so like my grandma
always cook this for me and this makes
me happy all the time and next to oinari
Sam
this like gorgeous sushi roll it's like
Japanese version of California roll
oh
one thousand percent better than
California World
in English it's like dried gourd roll is
perfect sushi roll and last one we have
pickles radish pickles it's quite yellow
it definitely has yellow number five
[Music]
I'm gonna give them Grammy Award
and stand in our vision
ah the hot food is a 7-Eleven in the U.S
we got a lot of options not as many as
Japan I'm not quite sure what some of
this stuff is just by looking at it so
let me go down the list nachos they're
the self-service nachos so they have the
chips ready to go and then you just open
them up and add cheese and chili onto
them
oh no thank you over here these mini
tacos man these like really
remember my face
oh man I've been sitting for a while so
I forgive them we also have wings crispy
and
not so crispy I like a bean burrito guy
over here in the roller Taquito section
you can get a barbecue bacon
cheeseburger roller spicy garlic roller
regular Taquito Korean barbecue Taquito
also we have chicken sandwiches a black
bean burger glazed cheesy barbecue
meatballs also at our 7-Elevens you get
a pepperoni pizza cheese or Seven Meats
and also for hot dogs we got an
exclusive hot picante dog
so here are our hot food sections we've
got steamed buns it's got pork and
bamboo shoots and this is really
standard like nikum so next size up we
have
the doubled nikuma and next one this
little guy
what is this
sweet beans skimped one and last steamed
bun is
Pizza bun
[Music]
delicious so all these things like
around 100 yen Cube 200 yen or so so if
you're broke you should definitely try
this we've got
these ones this one is called
so I deep fried Curry bread I want to
eat this
I want to eat this right now it doesn't
holy moly
freaking delicious and next one Crockett
so it's basically got potato and pork
means unless hot food we've got is corn
dog
so this one right here is pretty
Japanese one it's got ketchup and a
mustard and you just squeeze this one
onto this one all right
in Japan we have these chicken options
first I'm gonna start with this one
so in Japan when you make Japanese Fried
Chicken you put some soy sauce on it so
it has soy sauce flavor and also garlic
flavor so freaky delicious so this
karaoke boys got uh one two three and
four characters we have fried chicken
spicy fried chicken chicken nuggets
hot sandwich the buffalo style chicken
slider the cheeseburger and the bacon
cheeseburger I mean can you even tell
which ones right which one
yeah
I'm assuming obvious Burger's been
cooked
more on this in the ingredients section
uh 7-Eleven in the U.S
I think probably here in Southern
California has tacos and burritos get
yourself a chicken fajita taco
al pastor Taco bet this one's good and a
chorizo breakfast taco the spicy beef
bean and cheese burrito this ain't any
burrito baby it's the bomb
ing out the toilet good God you're
getting this and you're microwaving it
there so if you could be like walking
out to 7-Eleven chopping on the bottom
like
better make it home in time because oh
man it's coming empanadas right
I'm gonna go ahead and put this in here
and I close the lid like it's a coffin
go away forever all right so here are my
favorite bentos
take a look at this one it's called
this one is pretty popular one in Japan
so it's got Crockett a deep fried fish
cake fried fish with tartar sauce
it's like Japanese traditional salad
pickles and as you can see right here
it's got spicy cotton roll under this
seaweed it's got rice and fish flakes I
love this pencil like when I was a
student I think I would eat this every
single day so after my favorite one this
one look at this so this one is a Korean
style beef Bento oh man it smells so
good
everything right here is so amazing
fantastic this is so mushy soyo
and it comes with this sauce for this
tongratsu look how thick it is so
outside from bentos we have soba soba
noodle
put this sauce first
put Wasabi and dried seaweed and then
you put water onto soba noodle it's
getting moist
and don't forget to put green onions
right here
in this box
thank you
I guarantee you can't stop eating this
because it's so delicious sorry I still
love the noodles because Japanese people
or Asian people do make noises when you
eat noodles we slurp so LARP solar up
right now they got the meals over there
in Japan we got meals too like this
ready-made ricotta Romano parmesan
cheese stuffed ravioli top with marinara
sauce
just stop stop doing this stop please
stop oh then so then it's like Japanese
traditional hotspot it's got a fish cake
fried tofu noodle thing this is made
from potato egg radish in winter when
you eat this this warms you up from your
heart
to your body and next gratin Doria so
obviously it's got meat sauce and a lot
of cheese under this cheese it's got a
lot of rice in there it's like Japanese
Western food we have seven premium main
dishes naan and butter chicken curry and
next we have seven premium side dishes
mackerel grilled mackerel we also have
material in miso Saba miso is
smoked tank in Japan it's pretty popular
item especially when you go to like
Japanese barbecue restaurant we order
the like beef tongue or pigtung so this
one used to be like this
smells so good so fancy
[Music]
it's marvelous so after this sexy tongue
we have sexy fish cake and look at this
bar it's a chicken bar so it's like a
chicken nugget before it's fried octopus
and wasabi this is just raw octopus Kim
pirago it's a sauteed bird dog
hijiki seaweed and potato salad so like
when I go home my mom always Cooks like
this one this one this one I love you
Mom I miss mom's cooking and next we
have Premium Gold main dishes shrimp
with chili sauce beef stew
hamburger steak
sandwiches 7-Eleven egg salad peanut
butter and jelly turkey and cheddar
cheese and a kaiser roll so we have the
Italian style
so but then we also got
The Italian Job
turkey and ham with is that cheese in
the picture there we got the smoked
turkey and Monterey Jack cheese sandwich
and they separated the lettuce so you
add it like right before you're ready to
eat so it's still nice and crisp salads
chicken Caesar salad we also have a
pepperoni pasta salad so here are my
favorite sandwiches it's a tuna right
here and a cheese and lettuce and the
rest of these are ham and egg
I thought this is normal but you don't
have this one fruit sandwich
it's got a whole bunch of fruits it's
got Peach pineapples and oranges whipped
cream so it's like cake so here is seven
premium drip coffee so I'm gonna make
myself a cup of coffee
yes it's sit here
laughs
all right you gotta give us
it tastes like
so for breakfast sandwiches at 7-Eleven
you can get yourself a croissant with
ham egg and cheese ooh an English muffin
with bacon egg and cheese we also have
English Muffins with sausage egg and
cheese sausage biscuits and sausage egg
and cheese croissants the 7-Eleven
signature brand also has mini donuts
chocolate cinnamon crunch and of course
powdered madeleines 7-Eleven as cookies
right at the register for a dollar you
can get yourself some macadamia nut
cookies oatmeal raisin sugar but there's
also chocolate chip cookie one uh baked
goods you get yourself some muffins
there's a blueberry muffin coffee cake
crispy rice treat bar nothing say Rice
Crispy because you know that's quite
copper written Walnut fudge brownie bear
claw Danish iced honey bun cheese danish
mixed berry Danish glazed honey bun look
at these pre-packaged it says flavored
snack pie it's a weird way of putting it
lemon key lime banana cream
I feel like they used the same as the
same as Photoshop right there buddy
Boston cream apple and the last one
strawberry cheesecake key lime
it's key limey oh yeah oatmeal that's
obviously maple syrup right there but
the first thing I did when I looked at
it I was like wait is it a brandy in it
boozy oatmeal you can put hot water in
here Joe or hot milk Julie or hot
whiskey your boss won't notice the
difference
oh at first
here we have Japanese type of
fried noodles
all spread we call it yakistoba now you
might be thinking what the
what is this
it's like hot dog but instead of sausage
we got stir-fried noodle inside carb
carb it makes you fat bread makes you
fat so kids love this Noodle and bread
itadakimasu
this one reminds me of my childhood me
playing tags in the mountain and chasing
the girls
now a lot of girls
chasing me
this is a crab bread it's got two crab
shaped bread now the question is does it
taste like crab
it doesn't taste like crab tastes like
the spread pink bread it's a cherry
blossom flavored calling bread this pink
stuff is it's pretty sour
it tastes like cherry blossom and like
my first kiss this is the salty Savory
snack Zone ah so much stuff and I've hit
the food Wars wall hot and spicy
crackling kernels the original and the
fried pork rinds chili lime
I'm not tasting anything pork related to
it a little pig guy there
little thing again you're on the menu
buddy next seven selects has their own
veggie straws this will be the trail mix
and mix like section we got these uh
cheese pizza flavored snack mix damn
stinky boy if you have a bunch of these
yeah we got the spicy ranch flavor mix
and this last one just sesame sticks for
those of you who like to uh get your
trail mix or your Chex Mix and then
unmix them and organize them and eat
them like that 7-Eleven it's got a snack
for you oh this is kind of a party snack
mix yeah this is what I would totally
get yogurt yogurt pretzels I put yogurt
on there like you're thinking oh yogurt
that's healthy right it's just it's the
same as icing now you're looking at this
going Jack Links beef jerky that's not a
7-Eleven brand no it's not but as you
can see exclusive 7-Eleven flavors see
this was like hey jacklinks guess what
we're about to push you out on the show
on our Shelf space so do a deal with us
you're gone completely Jack Link's like
no I got kids to feed please brown sugar
bourbon
original recipe original hickory smoked
bacon like snacking on cheese and
nothing else Full House baby this one is
mozzarella cheese wrapped in hard salami
pepper jack stick gouda cheese to go oh
it's a big one The Big Cheese the white
cheddar this ain't your grandma's cheese
it's the big one
just two cheddar cheese colby jack which
is like camouflage cheese
pretzels mini Twist non-yoghurted
Pretzel nuggets oh gross this one's a
peanut butter inside of them pretzel
sticks I feel like there was a wild
there in the early 90s when they were
like chips are bad for you eat pretzels
instead these are really salty too a
serving size of these is three I would
get this assuming I'm gonna sit and eat
this whole bag in one setting and I can
do three at a time the whole bag is 1160
milligrams 50 of your sodium intake mini
rice cakes
chips 7-Eleven has a bunch of their own
potato chips including the original
fiery hot kettle chips which are way
better than regular chips again spicy
jalapeno smoked gouda barbecue
salt and pepper Ruffles rip-offs we got
cheddar and sour cream prime rib I'm
trying these and buffalo chicken dip
prime rib oh smells terrible
oh my God so so bad it's definitely not
this
I have more like ground beef instead of
one of these like fancy Forks it'd be
like a the plastic Spork that they have
at 7-Eleven they're opening the bag with
the spork meat's pouring out of it on
the floor of a 7-Eleven with a guy
mopping around it
nuts baby nuts The Rise and Shine fiber
blend of a trail mix whatever
antioxidants yeah right revive and
Thrive anti another antioxidant mix
should have just should have just handed
these out during coven would it bounced
back in a week cashew halves
you like your nuts halved oh yeah you
like like a nuts hold Booyah it doesn't
matter if they're whole or not that
would that affect the flavor at all who
cares spicy ranch
pistachios and of course jumbo flavored
Wasabi and soy nuts nope Wasabi will
never touch my lips again after that
after that video so here are my
favorites instant noodles let's start
eat Pudo Ramen man I love this so it's
got some Pockets like you ride pork it's
a missile for the ramen soup dried
veggies
and it's got noodles
[Music]
all right
and you're gonna wait for three minutes
so while I'm waiting for this I'm gonna
go this one so it's called
so it basically is a yaksoba you
actually is like a Japanese stir-fried
noodles
so you put some hot water until this
line
all right so it's been three minutes put
the soup into this bowl mix it
slow song
[Music]
Breville
say poodle has a lot of locations in
Japan included in Tokyo but this taste
this flavor is totally the same as the
restaurant serving so
let's get it at 7-Eleven
totally forget that oh
so I put some hot water but oh
I should have thrown the water away into
the toilet
noodles let's make yakisoba
the volume of these noodles
gets a lot bigger
okay so put yakisoba sauce
and flakes
and most importantly Mayo mayobi
and mix it up
so this is yakisoba but we usually it is
like at like Summer Festival
pretty good as always next we have
takomeshi
look at this it's got uh green onions
and I believe this is Taco
[Applause]
so three minutes again
look at this final noodle it says Ultra
spicy final you're gonna be crying
because of the spices it's too spicy but
I'm gonna try this only for a shooting
purpose this is for you guys
oh man I'm so scared
all right so I think it's time to eat
this one so I'm gonna throw the water
away in the toilet again let's go to the
toilet
sauce
alrighty
[Music]
The Taste itself is lighter than this
one I prefer this one but but this is
the king Ramen all right so finally
let's make a freaking spicy noodle I
call it death
in case I'm dead
please find another Japanese host it was
nice to meet you put inside her cool
oh man look at this it's not red
blood how do I need this
[Music]
ah
this is for you guys
[Music]
I'm joking I'm not joking
Hearts ah
on my life
am I not dead I'm in heaven
hell
I feel like I'm in hell it's not all
junk food at the 7-Eleven Joe and Julie
they also have delicious freshly sliced
fruits pre-packaged and everything came
straight from the ground and it comes in
a container that will be here
until the sun explodes this I mean this
has to be an LA thing you can get a
mango with tahini seasoning fantastic
combination finally grape cup 7-Eleven
also has its own brand of packaged
candies
sour gummy bears sour neon gummy worms
Tower watermelon wedges green apple
rings gummy worms for catching gummy
fish I like that fruit leather remember
what we call this chili mango Ellie I'm
trying these sweet and mango and a
sweetened fruit medley
oh
also gummy bears and gummy sharks it's
also gummy peach rings they got jelly
beans and they got sour cherries
7-Eleven selects in the US also has
their own line of sandwich cookies
vanilla pumpkin spice
double chocolates peppermint s'mores the
duplexes lemon cream
so here are Japanese sweets pink rice
cake with red bean paste so basically uh
it's like cherry blossom mochi
I want to eat this under the tree of
cherry blossom
foreign
it's really tough like stones
it's like Porky but like the chocolate
is inside
I'm loving it look at this cute guy
[Music]
koalas marriage chocolate
my favorite will be this one
when I was a kid I would eat this every
single day and this taste is so
nostalgic a little George is calling me
like
hey I want to hit this I want it hey
feel me
later after shooting okay okay
we're good pretty
please prepare the plate and you just do
like this one two three go
this shape is like cherry blossom look
how jelly it is
[Music]
this is the best pudding ever we had to
go on a run to get more stuff that's why
visually this all doesn't connect so
everyone's got macaroons French
macaroons mini cheesecakes New York
style and strawberry swirl these I can
get behind our 7-Eleven in the US has
ice cream such as banana cream pie
caramel butter pecan chocolate covered
strawberry double cookie dough cookies
and cream sea salt caramel strawberry
banana Shortcake so let's start with
cold stuff we've got fried dumplings
Frozen Frozen Taco Yaki Frozen fried
rice
so after these frozen meals I got ice
cream
is like Japanese ice cream sandwich
[Music]
sorry it looks gross so it's got ice
cream and it's got chocolate in the
middle and uh this crunchy on the
outside every Japanese people get this
one at least once in their life and last
ice cream I got this one gorilla
chocolate ice cream
I don't know what this is
[Music]
[Laughter]
delicious
not only me but gorilla would love this
a lot of exclusive drinks uh I don't
really want to begin so I kind of lined
them up by perception of healthiness
it's all the way down on this end we've
got 7-Eleven select go smart cold
organic pressed juices this one's the
tropical glow and this gross looking one
is of course cleaning green
after that we got these pre-packaged
juices these are the seven select
Farmers Grove cranberry cocktail
raspberry lemonade orange juice of
course regular lemonade then next up in
the bigger ones we have the 7 11 teas
peach black tea sweet tea they weren't
kidding man look at that lemon sweet tea
and
green tea fruit punch mango guava energy
come on herbal tonic herbal dessertable
guys yeah 7-Eleven also has their own
brand of are these energy drinks the
Gatorades and powerades and the like
replenish and of course replenish zero
I'm assuming zero added sugar orange
mango fruit punch lemonade the Cherry is
clear what why is Cherry clear guava
Splash orange mango these are bad
7-Eleven energy
strawberry lemonade energy shot one and
a half times of caffeine of a cup of
coffee oh good God
undrinkable how bad is that the taste
where this is two I can get to this
you've seen the show right you'll see
what I'll tolerate this I can barely
tolerate this
here's something that they don't have in
Japan they don't have Slurpees that's
nuts right Slurpees are how do you
describe a Slurpee it's like a flavored
slush uh we have endless Slurpee flavors
and once currently you can get here in
America are blue rocket Berry blood
orange Vitamin Water XXX blue raspberry
blueberry lemonade Bliss cherry
Coca-Cola Mountain Dew Citrus peach
perfect pina colada and pineapple whip
so here are Japanese exclusive drinks we
have vegetable juice of course
a lot of Japanese celery Men drink this
one every morning to get their day
started so this one is for Joe Joe
you're missing a lot of badges so you
should drink this one
my favorite green tea and these two are
hot drinks black coffee and coffee latte
and this is our first time filmmakers we
have alcohol we have seven premium beer
and this one is not beer it's like
Sprite with alcohol it contains nine
percent of alcohol it's pretty delicious
but at the same time it's pretty
dangerous Japanese sake
when you come to Japan you can see a lot
of people drinking alcohol outside they
were like
they're not dead they're just sleeping
they're drunk whiskey
7-Eleven in the U.S has its own private
brand wines Yosemite Road Trojan Horse
plot and point and Voyager point it also
has its own canned wine brand called
Roamer perhaps the reason 7-Eleven has
such a wide variety of products in Japan
is that it's everywhere in Japan there
are 21
215 stores in Japan that's crazy which
is nearly 30 percent of all the
7-Elevens in the world of course all 37
prefectures have a 7-Eleven and out of
all of them the city of Tokyo has the
most locations with
2850. to put that in perspective the US
has
9417 7-Eleven and there's no 7-Elevens
in 18 states as far as States California
has the most
1823 but as far as denseness in area Las
Vegas Nevada has the most with a hundred
and 58.
[Music]
in Japan our hot dog is 290 calories and
720 milligrams of sodium which is 31.3
percent of your daily allowance
our hot dog is 180 calories
our hot dog is 180 calories but for the
Frank only the stats for some reason
don't say anything about the bun but
this isn't much better for you it's 570
milligrams of sodium so around 24.8
percent of your daily alarms Japan's
handy rolled tuna and Mayo onigiri has
258 calories and is very filling
remember this guy the tuna sandwich here
in the US ours is 420 calories and lots
of sodium over 800 milligrams
and in the U.S a super big gulp of
Coca-Cola this is in Coca-Cola is 44
fluid ounces it's 513 calories and 143
grams of carbs it's over half your daily
intake
[Music]
in Japan 7-Eleven does not disclose the
ingredients list of especially made food
items it does however tell us the
country of origin for the raw materials
for certain items like a Friday food
Yakitori Oden and Chinese steamed buns
the chicken for our Fried Chicken is
from Thailand the pork for our sausages
and hot dogs comes from USA Canada and
Japan the wheat for the Buns comes from
Canada the USA and Japan and asuki beans
come from Canada cheese comes from New
Zealand and the shrimp for the shrimp
chili buns is from Vietnam this is the
pepperoni the pizza in the U.S and it
contains all this junk
I mean
what's this thing never heard of that
what about chicken strips it's got all
this stuff just like Mom used to make
and of course the 7-Eleven select
cheeseburger which contains sesame seed
bun has enriched flour excuse me
enriched wheat flour wheat flour nice
and silver produced iron Mano Sarah
today
calcium carbonate is a preservative
calcium sulfate Patty stuff got smoke
flavor added adds beef encapsulated
itself anything else out of that salt
spice pasteurized processor cheese
they're sitting down that's how long
this is going the camera person just sat
down a preservative paprika and annetto
color so I guess the last take away from
this video is that in the U.S some of
our 7-Eleven items can be a little bit
of a gamble with your health speaking of
gambling you know your boy got some
scratches when he was over at 7-Eleven
okay so there's the winning numbers okay
so we don't win anything on that one
I have no clue how to do this did I win
if you haven't subscribed yet subscribe
now
because we are filming this for six
hours